bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce troisième cours de paléo
mammalogie le deuxième sur les ongulés
ongulés partie de donc la dernière fois
nous avons vu les ongulés qui sont les
herbivores de grande taille dominant que
sont les arts cieux dactyle et l'épée
risso d'actes il est aujourd'hui nous
allons voir un groupe dont bull et qui
est un peu plus discret aujourd'hui mais
qui a eu une très très grande et longue
histoire évolutive et ce groupe c le
groupe dp nom du lait dans lequel on
retrouve les éléphants les lamantins et
les dames ans qu'on appelle aussi irak
ce donc les éléphants bon bah évidemment
on ne présente pas les éléphants tout le
monde connaît les lamantins font partie
du groupe peuvent être décrits comme
étant des ongulés alors malgré le fait
que ce soit des mammifères marins
herbivores donc le dugong et le lamentin
ont des sabots vous voyez qu'ils sont
visibles ici sur le bout de leurs de
l'heure de leur palette natatoire et les
dames en donc qui sont ces petits
animaux qui ressemble un peu à un mix
entre un rongeur un pikachu et 1 et un
lapin voilà donc les dames en que vous
n'avez probablement jamais vu parce
qu'ils sont les eaux sont pas très
intéressés à avoir des dames en et bien
ils ont aussi des petits sabots vous
voyez que c'est pas un rongeur le damman
il sait c'est pas un rongeur parce que
voyez il a des petites servent des
petits sabots et pas des griffes et tous
ces groupes ont une longue histoire
évolutive un long registre fossile qui
documentent leurs ancêtres qui était
beaucoup plus semblables à l'idée qu'on
se fait aujourd'hui d'un onglet typique
mais voilà les pennons gueulé en gros ce
sont les ongulés qui ont une gueule
ils ont une gueule
et ils ont ceci de particulier qu'ils
n'ont rien sur leur sur la morphologie
de leurs pattes
finalement qui les distingue des autres
on avait vu enfin il y a des choses sur
la morphologie de leurs pattes qu'on va
voir juste après mais si vous voulez y a
rien d'aussi évident que s'il y a un axe
de symétrie au milieu c'est un pays
chaud dactyle et s'il ya un axe de
symétrie entre deux doigts
c'est un art sio d'actifs voilà il ya
rien au cid aussi facile à gérer que ça
avec les pennons gül et donc on va se
servir d'autres caractères qui sont qui
sont communs à tous les paiements gül et
le premier c'est la morphologie lofo
d'hondt des dents donc là vous avez un
lamentable par exemple vous voyez que
les dents porte deux l'ofs
chacun chacune donc c'est assez clair le
lamantin qui a la particularité d'avoir
les dents qui se renouvelle en tapis
roulant de l'arrière à l'avant on verra
ça un peu plus loin ici vous voyez le
donc un dame en irak ce avec voyez les
deux love qui ressemble beaucoup
d'ailleurs à la morphologie con qu'on
connaît chez les ch et les chevaux bazzo
d'ailleurs c'est pas pour rien que les
irak ce ont donné leur nom à irako
terium qui est l'un des chevaux les plus
banales donc voilà il ya une connexion
ici c'est parce que leur morphologie
dentaire est très ressemblante
parce qu'elle est l'eau faut donc avec
un l'ofs extérieur en plus donc un
hectos lov et de lov et évidemment comme
c'est les ongulés ils ont des dents
carré et les éléphants alors les
éléphants voilà une dent d'éléphant
c'est vachement bizarre une dent
d'éléphant c'est très très gros ça peut
peser de 3 à 5 kilos mais les éléphants
ici vous avez la racine et là vous avez
la couronne donc ce sont des dents
extrêmement ipso dont un très très hot
et au sommet de cette couronne mais à
vous avez sell-off donc on va voir un
peu plus loin comment d'une morphologie
l'eau faut donc assez similaire à celle
du damman finalement est bien de tel nof
ont pu se multiplier sur les dents des
éléphants voilà donc ça c'est un autre
caractère comme un os
hop et non du lait à caractère du crâne
ils ont un crâne hamas tauhid un peu
comme les cétacés donc ça veut dire que
le pétrole ne participe pas à la boîte
crânienne et ça c'est notable pour un
mammifère terrestre et donc le caractère
de leurs mains et de leurs pieds donc
comme je le disais vous pouvez toujours
chercher un axe de symétrie vous n'en
trouverez pas les éléphants vous le
voyez les trois doigts du milieu sont
les doigts porteurs de charge et celle
et d'assister le doigt du milieu en fait
c'est comme un père i saw dactyle
d'ailleurs on a beaucoup pensent on a
très longtemps pensé que les que les
dames ans était en fait
conecteo périssent au dactyle est pas
tellement au bénin gül et donc c'est pas
c'est pas au niveau de la morphologie
des doigts que ça va se jouer
c'est au niveau de la morphologie des
carpes et des tares ce donc si vous
regardez les carpes chez un animal chez
un mammifère classiques comme un humain
c'est un peu organisés façon puzzle
voilà façon pub comme dirait l'autre
donc c'est un patron alternée en fait
deux bombes c'est le bordel quoi alors
que quand on regarde la main d'un
éléphant ou le pied d'un éléphant et
bien les carpes et les tard ce sont bien
alignés donc là vous voyez les mains par
exemple parce que ça me permet de
comparer aussi les siréniens et bien
vous voyez l'ul na est aligné avec une
première rangée de carpes qui est aligné
avec ce douala et puis le radius il est
aligné avec une deuxième rangée de
cartes qui est aligné avec ce douala et
puis ce douala il est aussi aligné avec
une rangée de cartes et l'appareil
l'ul na est aligné avec une rangée de
carpes et un doigt le radius avec une
autre rangée de carpes et un doigt et le
troisième douala enfin le doigt numéro 2
pardon est aligné avec lui aussi avec sa
rangée de cartes particulière et c'est
pareil aussi chez les sirénia up bel
alignement très visible donc voilà s'il
est si les carpes et létard se sont bien
ordonné que vous avez pas apple
et bien c'est à peine ont vu les voilà
donc ça c'est la morphologie typique du
de la main des paiements gül et qui
s'appelle la morphologie taxés au pod
voilà si vous cherchez
on avait les mehak sonia on avait les
parades saunière maintenant on allait
taxer au pod autre chose visible sur le
crâne de la plupart des paiements gueulé
alors c'est visible chez les pennons
gueulé monde moderne c'est pas toujours
visible chez les pédoncules et fossiles
c'est la position de l'oeil donc la
position de l'oeil de l'orbité chez les
chez les dames en vous pouvez voir et
très en avant sur le crâne donc
généralement en avant de la prémolaires
voyez le bord antérieure de l'orbité en
avant de la 4è prémolaires et ça ça se
voit ça se voit évidemment chez
l'éléphant l'éléphant les éléphants lors
beat quasiment le quasiment toutes à
l'avant du crâne les sirénia vous voyez
la rangée dentaire qui se termine ici il
est le bord intérieur de leurs beats qui
se termina en à peu près au même niveau
que la rangée dentaire et si vous prenez
un éléphant fossiles comme moi yari
terium un proboscidiens fossiles pardon
comme moyens matériels vous voyez la
rangée dentaire ici donc un deux trois
mots l'air ici là prémolaires et vous
voyez que l'orbité très très en avant de
la 4è prémolaires donc voilà ça c'est un
autre caractère de paix non du lait
qu'on retrouve comme je le disais c'est
ça peut ça peut être utile dans la
plupart des cas mais il ya certains cas
chez certains zeerax notamment chez qui
le museau et très allongée et du coup
c'est très difficile de dire enfin le
caractère ce caractère et perdu en fait
et puis évidemment comme on comme il
faut bien parler d'eux le pénis et de
testicules pendant ma montcourt sinon
personne n'est intéressé
eh bien il ya aussi des caractères sur
les testicules les pennons gueulé sont
parmi les rares mammifères à avoir les
testicules qui sont dans l'abdomen et
pas à l'extérieur
donc c'est un caractère comme je le dit
qui est assez rare parmi les mammifères
bien que ce soit la norme chez la
plupart des autres
groupes de vertébrés et enfin un
caractère le enfin particularité assez
importante mais que j'avais déjà précisé
la dernière fois eh bien ce sont les
seuls sons gül et qui ont une véritable
origine africaine puisqu'ils font partie
des afro teria donc voilà le clad des
afro teria en rouge et vous voyez les
pennons gueulé en font partie et le club
des afro tarja bien c'est le clac des
mammifères qui sont soit endémique
d'afrique soit qui ont une véritable
origine africaine et en l'occurrence
l'origine des affreux teria serait à
retracer jusqu au crétacé alors on n'a
pas encore de fossile aussi vieux que ça
mais c'est ce qu'indique c'est ce
qu'indique l'horloge moléculaire
elle serait à retracer jusqu au crétacé
à une époque où l'afrique était isolé du
reste du monde
pas encore entré en collision avec
l'eurasie suite à la tectonique des
plaques et donc l'ancêtre commun des
affreux terre se serait retrouvée isolée
sur le continent africain
et c'est comme ça qu'il aurait évolué
dans toutes ces différents types
écologiques qui sont finalement assez
similaire à ce qu'on retrouve pas chez
les marsupiaux et chez les lourds asia
enfin les bords et aux étés ria donc les
marsupiaux sont là les bourgs et au et
arrière est là et chacun dans son coin
en fait en australie en lors asie et en
afrique vont évoluer mais finalement les
mêmes types écologique donc des cétacés
des rongeurs des grands herbivores
d
des fours milliers d puis d'autres
animaux des petit insectivore et
d'autres trucs qui ressemble à des
rongeurs donc voilà c'est assez
intéressant de comparer justement les
convergence évolutive dû au fait que
finalement comme il n'y avait pas de
concurrence
ils ont pu se diversifier librement dans
tous les types écologique et dans les
mêmes types écologique que les
mammifères sur d'autres continents où il
était aussi isolé alors le plus ancien
peinons bull est connu c'est le plus bas
à l'eau si c'est pas seulement le plus
ancien c'est aussi le plus banal coc
paya qui est donc un candidat retr une
fois de plus donc pouvait voir au cp ya
à l'image ici il est reconstruit comme
un homme ressemblant 1 dames ans parce
que évidemment c'est le damman et le
moins spécialisés des paiements gül et
ce n'est pas un mammifère marin né un
truc avec une trompe donc par défaut on
va dire que c'est à ça que ressemble et
l'ancêtre des paiements gueulé mais
voilà vous pouvez reconnaître ici donc
c'est les dents et le palais de den osse
paya et vous pouvez voir la halle aux
faux nom s'il est dans l'eau fonds dont
elles sont très faiblement low faut
noter fortement bras kid honte parce que
évidemment c'est un conte dillard donc
c'est un animal assez basale peu
spécialisé et très certainement mangeurs
de feuilles et de fruits
donc voilà le quand je vous disais que
le groupe des candidats retr c'est un
peu tout et n'importe quoi
un coup on le retrouve à la base des
paiements gueulé un coup elle retrouve à
la base des péris seul acte il a coup à
la base de cet arceau dactyle c'est un
peu un groupe pour tous pour tous les
ancêtres de ce qu'il ya des sabots en
fait alors les afro terre ça a été un
groupe
évidemment tout le monde n'y a pas cru
dès le premier jour la première fois
qu'on a commencé à parler d'un clad qui
rassemblerait les taupes doré avec les
éléphants
c'est en 1981 déjà et un autre article
en 1984 où il avait utilisé des
protéines des séquences protéique et
pouf en comparant les séquences
protéique ils ont eu ce clad qui
unissait les tops dorer les éléphants et
il me semble qu il y avait les
les oryctérope aussi donc voilà c'est
c'est la première fois que ces sorties
évidemment personne n'y a cru
donc ils ont comment ils ont comparé
plein de protéines puis ils ont rajouté
les gènes dans les années 90 et puis
arrivé dans les années 1980 enfin arrivé
sur la fin des années 90 en 1998 on
avait tellement de gênes qui pointaient
tous dans la même direction parce qu'à
force de comparer gêne après gêne et de
retrouver tout le temps le même arbre on
a fini par se dire bien évidemment il ya
quelque chose qui se passe quoi donc à
porte
à force de retrouver tout le temps le
même résultat est bien là cette année
aux pétales donc des américains ont
décidé de baptiser le clad d'une onde a
frotté arias qui n'a pas du tout plu aux
morphologies évidemment aux
paléontologues puisque marc faut
logiquement il veut rien dire ce qu là
d'un jeu dire vous avez des herbivores
terrestre des herbivores aquatique vous
avez des rongeurs vous avez des
fourmilier vous avez de tout dans ce cas
de morphologiquement il veut rien dire
ce club mais il ya des signes à pau
morphy au niveau des gènes et on rajoute
des gènes encore et encore et on rajoute
même au bout d'un moment on finit par
ajouter des données génomiques donc des
génomes tout entier et les génomes tout
entier raconte la même histoire que les
gènes et même au courant des années 2000
on a fini par ajouter des rétros posant
c'est à dire des gènes sauteurs c'est à
dire des gènes qui saute d'un endroits
du chromosome à un autre d'une
génération à une autre en fait ils
sautent d'un endroit à un autre du
génome et du coup il ya une très très
très faible probabilité qu'un rétro
pause hausse on saute deux fois au même
endroit par accident la probabilité est
extrêmement faible
et pour le coup et ben et les mains les
afro terre partage plein de rétro posons
donc
donc maintenant on a des événements
génomique rares comme l'insertion de
transposons l'insertion de rétro posons
des délétions des délétions entière de
partie du génome très importante qu'on
ne retrouve chez aucun autre mammifère
et des additions donc voilà tous ces
événements génomique rare toutes les
séquences de génome tous pointent dans
la direction et les protéines pointent
dans la direction d'héma 1000 d afro
terre de l'existence des afro terre donc
oui il y à bien un ancêtre commun à tous
bords
au delà il ya bien d'ancêtres comme à
cette bestiole qui ressemble à
fourmiller cette bestiole qui est un
éléphant cette bestiole qui est un
mammifère marin et c'est top
et voilà donc toutes ces bestioles ont
un ancêtre commun est là et bien
maintenant c'est aux paléontologues de
se démerder pour savoir à quoi il
ressemblait voilà et bon spoiler alert
on sait pas spoiler alert on ne sait pas
évidemment je vous ai montré le plus
ancien qu'on dit la retraitée le plus
ancien pédonculé et vous pouvez voir
qu'il ressemble déjà peu ou prou un
damman donc et de l'autre côté
et puis de l'autre côté le problème
c'est que les pennons gueulé ont un très
beau registre fossile mais alors de
l'autre côté c'est c'est pas du tout la
même sauce aller de l'autre côté vous
avez donc les les afro terre
insectivores si je puis dire avec les
les mangeurs de les mangeurs de fourmies
et puis les les autres les autres
mangeurs d'invertébrés quoi et donc
parmi ces afro tard affectivement on a
calé le registre fossile ne nous indique
que rien de bien excitant quoi les
oryctérope autant pour autant qu'on
sache ils ont toujours ressemblé à
désorienter rock le plus vieux fossile
de du miocène les maquereaux c'est
l'idée on a des fossiles qui datent de
l'éocène mais bon c'est que des dents et
c'est que des dans un petit peu de
cheville puis une oreille interne quoi
donc c'est pas non plus ça suffit pas
avoir une idée de ce à quoi ressemblait
ancêtres des macros c'est une idée quoi
et puis les afro saurai sida donc les
temps rec et les tops doré bas alors là
ils ont toujours eu la même gueule on a
des toc doré qui datent de l'éocène et
elles ont une gueule de top doré donc
mais on verra ça dans le détail un peu
plus loin dans un prochain cours donc
voilà les afro terre
c'est toujours un mystère la leçon du
jour et alors les afro terre aujourd'hui
c'est un groupe qui a pris cher dans sa
race parce que c'est passé en fait du
groupe dominant de mammifères en afrique
pendant pendant l'histoire évolutive des
mammifères les afro terre sont passés du
groupe dominant de mammifères en afrique
à une poignée d'espèces donc voilà on a
un oryctérope vingt-et-une top doré 30
tant règles 17-17 haha trompe seulement
quatre espèces de 2 siréniens seulement
cinq espèces d'irak aux ide et seulement
deux ou peut être trois espèces
d'éléphants si vous considérez
l'éléphant des forêts comme une espèce
d'éléphants distinctes
donc voilà ça c'est la totalité de la
diversité des afro terre et alors si
vous gardez que les paiements gül et là
vous avez vraiment que le pâle reflet de
la richesse de la de la magnifique
diversité qu'ils étaient autrefois mais
ça on va l'explorer deux autres fois les
afro terre il y en avait partout penser
rien qu au mammouth penser aux mammouths
donc un éléphant un proboscidiens
fossiles
on ne peut plus célèbres il y en avait
partout des mammouths voilà il y en
avait absolument partout et il y en
avait des dizaines d'espèces et puis
d'un seul coup plus rien donc voilà
voici la phylogénie que nous allons
suivre aujourd'hui donc les pennons
gueulé avec en premier les irak aux ide
et en deuxième les proboscidiens et les
siréniens et les siréniens qui forment
le clad d'été tit r alors commençons
d'abord par les irak aux ide comment
reconnaît-on en irak aux ide alors chez
les irakiens
déjà les irak aux ide ne sont limités
qu'à l'afrique et à quelques espèces au
moyen-orient espèces qui sont la relique
d'une diversité d'une grande diversité
et d'une
d'une dispersion d'une et d'une
émigration pardon du passé dont tout
repas dont on parlera dans la prochaine
yapo donc saisir accueillis dans les
reconnaît pas parce qu'ils ont des
défenses alors qu'on ne s'y trompe pas
ce ne sont pas des incisives
ce ne sont pas des incisives comme les
rongeurs se sont bel et bien des
défenses parce qu'elles n'ont pas
d'émail donc la différence entre une
défense et une incisive dans ce cas là
c'est la couche d'émail les rongeurs ont
une couche d'émail sur leur incisive pas
les dames en pas les irak aux ide
donc là on a bien des incisives qui sont
transformés en défense donc vous avez
une paire de défense pointu sur le
dessus et deux paires de défense spatule
et pro clive est en forme de peigne sur
le sur la mâchoire inférieure donc vous
voyez là on voit bien la forme pro clive
de ses incisives et là on voit bien la
forme pectiné vous pouvez l'appeler
pectiné vous pouvez l'appeler en forme
de peigne dentaire voilà avec les mâles
qui ont la deuxième paire d'incisives
plus grande que les femelles donc là
vous avez un glorieux mal devant vous
donc les irak aux ide bien aujourd'hui
les seules espèces qui survivent
ressemble globalement à des lapins avec
des petites oreilles mais évidemment ils
ont une grande grande diversité passé
alors cette longue histoire évolutive
elle se reflète sur leur crâne puisque
ce sont les seuls mammifères ou du moins
parmi les rares mammifères chez qui le
processus post orbitaire donc le la
petite barre là qui ferment leur [ __ ] à
l'arrière n'est pas formé par le frontal
mais par l'os pariétal donc vous voyez
normalement c'est le frontal qui devrait
passer là mais non la suture du frontal
viens ici et au dernier moment non je ne
vais pas voilà elle change de direction
et du coup c'est le pariétal qui
projette une petite langue osseuse qui
partis qui forment cette langue est ce
processus post orbitaire donc ça c'est
très caractéristique désira coheed vous
avez des dents des prémolaires qui sont
fortement mot la risée
donc encore une fois un animal herbivore
mais qui n'est pas ruminants dont qui a
besoin de deux prémolaires fortement
polarisé chez certaines espèces d'irak
aux ide éteinte
même la canine et mot la risée donc même
la canine finit par ressembler à une
molaire donc celle là c'est formidable
alors les tâches et les irako in modern
parce que parce que chez les irakiens de
moderne la canine est perdue vous voyez
qu'il ya un diastème mais les irakiens
ideta certaine forme de l'oligocène
n'avait pas de diastème et il avait
encore une canine et la canine échangés
en molaires en fait donc c'est vraiment
assez impressionnant donc là vous pouvez
voir un une de ces espèces de
l'oligocène mégalo irak ce donc vous
pouvez voir la rangée dentaires les
dents mollahs reform est ici vous voyez
toutes les autres dans donc là la canine
n'est pas beau la risée donc si vous
suivez une deux trois mots l'air une
deux trois quatre prémolaires est ici
vous avez donc la canine pardon c'est
celle-là ça c'est la canine
alors vous voyez quelle est elle est un
peu plus grosse qu'elle n'est censé
l'être donc elle est légèrement bolaris
forme et vous avez une incisive deux
incisives et la troisième est la
première paire d'incisives du cou qui
forment les défenses donc là les
défenses sont bien là la morphologie
dentaire et lofo donc avec un hectos
love come on les sens et la retrouver
chez les irakiens ils m'aiment et les
galeries racks vous pouvez le voir il
est balèze comparer en irak ce moderne
donc là le crâne 10 racks moderne il me
tient dans la main
donc là vous avez quand même un miracle
d'une taille assez conséquente et il y
avait des airs accent core plus gros
comme titane ou irak ce qui pouvait
atteindre la taille d'un rhinocéros et
vous aviez d irak ce qui était de taille
moyenne avec de très longues jambes un
museau très fin et qui ressemblaient à
des antilopes
et tout ça ça a vécu en fait ça s'est
diversifiée pendant les eaux seine et la
plupart des espèces 10 racks états ont
vécu pendant l'oligocène alors ici vous
voyez un arbre phylogénétique voici pro
kawiak à peine si ce qui représente
l'espèce moderne la plus la plus connue
et tout le reste c'est des espèces
fossiles tout le reste c'est des espèces
fossiles et 90% d'entre elles ont vécu à
la fin de l'éocène et durant l'oligocène
on les retrouve notamment dans le fayoum
en egypte mais on les retrouve en
réalité un peu partout en afrique c'est
un groupe vraiment qu'il ya eu une
diversité colossal pendant le pendant le
pendant le paléo j'aime pendant la
première moitié du cénozoïque pourquoi
parce qu'il n'y avait pas encore
darciaux d'actine ni de perry soda qd il
les a reçus au tactile et l'épée risso
dactyle ils n'arrivent commis aux scènes
et donc avant ça et bien les allées les
irak aux ide jouer le rôle darciaux
dactyle de perry soda et il jouait le
rôle des lapins y avait pas de lapin non
plus donc ils jouaient le rôle des
lapins bref ça c'était il faisait tout
les irak au vide
c'étaient les irako hideux multitâche et
puis au milieu scène il ya un pont il ya
un pont de terre qui va se former entre
l'afrique et l'asie au début du miocène
ya 21 millions d'années et alors il ya
les ars united les périodes at il qui
vont déferler en afrique ça va être une
catastrophe pour la diversité d irak aux
ide mais donc toutes ces espèces là
elles vont disparaître mais le groupe
désire axe moderne qu'on appelle les
pros cave idée du nom de pro cavia qui
est le damman du cap
ils vont connaître un petit rebond de
diversité et sortir d'afrique et on en
trouve et on en trouve en chine inde et
en chine on trouve même des formes semi
aquatique qui ressemblent un peu à des
hippopotames
enfin des tapirs pardon donc on trouve
des formes qui ressemble à des tapirs
et on en trouve même en europe et
notamment en france on a des fossiles
d'irak aux ide qui ont été découverts à
lyon qui ont été découverts à
montpellier donc même chez nous on a eu
des dames en mai tout ça ça va
disparaître à la fin du pliocène enfin
au mieux à la fin du pliocène sinon si
c'est pas carrément à la fin du miocène
donc hélas la diversité d irak aux ide
après l'oligocène ne fut plus jamais ce
qu'elle fut autrefois malgré ce petit
rebond on monte maintenant du coup vers
l'été tit r donc les têtes iter chez qui
on va retrouver les cirés n'y a donc là
vous voyez je suis déjà en train de
spoiler l'histoire des siréniens avec
monsireigne à quatre pattes les
proboscidiens dont je suis en train de
ce pôle et la formidable diversité pas
c'est que dans les quelques espèces
modernes ne sont que le pâle résidus et
les ans brito pod un groupe qui
ressemble au rhinocéros et qui est
complètement éteint alors déjà qu est-ce
qui va rassembler des espèces aussi
variés que les têtes iter là on a de
l'éléphant on a dû siréniens donc du
mammifère aquatique on a de lambris tôt
potes qui ressemble à du rhinocéros
alors qu'est ce qu'ils ont en commun ces
bestioles et ben en plus des gènes
évidemment il y as ils ont une
morphologie qui est vraiment très très
particulière alors déjà l'arcade du gal
est fortement projeté latéralement vous
voyez le l'arc que sa forme chez sept
ans brito potes c'est assez
impressionnant et ça on le retrouve chez
les éléphants comme chez les siréniens
donc déjà c'est un premier caractère
l'arcade zygomatique très très épaisse
et très fortement projeté latéralement
donc insertion du muscle master à ses
immenses 1 comme vous pouvez le voir sur
phase d'insertion assez développée
ensuite le ce qu'on appelle l'externat
l'auditori mathus donc c'est à dire le
trou pour l'oreille externe
c'est ni plus ni moins que le trou dans
le crâne pour l'oreille externe et bien
se trouve dans le crâne pour l'oreille
externe au lieu d'être sur le bord
inférieur du crâne comme il est censé
l'être chez tous les mammifères au final
donc vous prenez n'importe quel crâne le
donc prenons par exemple le damman de
tout à l'heure voilà le trou auditif
externe celle d'avancer cette petite
encoche convoi en bas du crâne voilà
donc c'est pas
et donc on voit directement cette
encoches si vous retournez le crâne on
voit directement cette encoches ici donc
voilà ça c'est le trou de l'oreille
externe
et ben non pas celle et et iter celle et
et iter ce trou de l'oreille externe il
se trouve profondément à l'intérieur de
l'os sauce quoi moselle donc
profondément à l'intérieur du crâne donc
si vous retournez le crâne en fait et
ben vous voyez pas de deux petites
encoches sur le dessous du crâne parce
que le trou est complètement à
l'intérieur du crâne et après si on
regarde un peu les tissus mous bat déjà
on va noter la forme du coeur alors on
peut pas le faire chez les embryons
potes parce qu'ils sont complètement
état mais chez les éléphants et sirénia
le coeur à deux pointes les ventricules
sont énormes et en fait au lieu d'avoir
un seul apex comme un coeur normale au
final eh bien ils ont à coeur avec deux
apex mais ça c'est quand même assez
impressionnant et sur le cerveau il ya
un élément très particulier alors ici
vous voyez le cerveau fraîchement
disséquer d'un éléphant vous pouvez voir
donc là toutes les tout le tout les
supplications du cortex se vous savez
cet aspect en forme de plates spaghetti
si caractéristique du cerveau est bien
quand vous avoir en fait d'atteindre le
cerveau il ya une couche de ménage comme
chez les êtres humains je le dire mais
sauf que chez les éléphants et chez les
sirènes ya cette couche de ménages est
tellement épaisse qu'en fait elle cache
complètement le patron de supplications
du cerveau donc en fait on peut pas voir
que le cerveau est en forme de spaghetti
en pleine forme de plat de spaghettis si
vous ne l'enlevez pas cette couche de
ménage et ça ça se retrouve c'est
intéressant parce que ça se retrouve
dans le registre fossile
si vous regardez le cerveau d'un
siréniens fossiles ou d'un an brito pod
et bien il est complètement lisse
pourquoi parce que enfin c'est pas le
cerveau si vous regardez le moulage de
la cavité crânienne d'un sirénia
fossiles ou d'un an brito pod ou d'un
éléphant fossiles eh bien vous ne verrez
pas non plus ces petites sulc à sion
vous verrez un moulage endocriniens
complètement lisse pourquoi bas parce
que justement les ménages recouvre tout
en fait donc toute la complexité du
cerveau et du néocortex est complètement
cachée par la couche de ménage et ça
c'est directement visibles sur le
registre fossile puisque cette couche de
ménage va laisser
une empreinte qui va pouvoir être moulés
sur le moulage endocriniens et enfin un
dernier petit caractère que je trouve
assez marrant c'est là les glandes
mammaires les glandes mammaires chez les
pennons bull et ne sont pas situés sur
l'abdomen comme elles le sont sur un
chien un chat un cochon une vache ou que
sais-je
elles sont situées sur la région
thoracique
donc c'est ce sont des glandes mammaires
pectoral du coup ça du coup les
éléphants et les siréniens on déniche on
voit littéralement et je suis sûr que
vous n'avez jamais fait gaffe
voilà la première fois que la prochaine
fois que vous allez voir les éléphants
auzolat vous mettrez vous verrez si
c'est une femelle là vous essayez de
voir les nichons des éléphants ça compte
pas comme de la zoophilie
je vous promets et puis il ya un petit
élément assez intéressant aussi niveau
biologie c'est que les éléphants sont
très à l'aise dans l'eau évidemment les
sirénia sont aussi très à l'aise dans
l'eau puisque ce sont des mammifères
marins et on sait d'après le registre
fossile que les ancêtres des éléphants
étaient aussi pas mal à l'aise dans
l'eau à vous voyez que bâle
il ressemblait un peu à des tapis rires
et puis on a fait des analyses
isotopiques et on a vu que leur eau leur
chimie osseuse
donc les analyses géochimiques pour ceux
qui savent pas ce que isotopique de dire
donc on fait une analyse de la chimie
des eaux et puis en fait la chimie des
eaux correspond à celle d'animaux sur
semi aquatiques comme les tapirs donc
don qui a l'air d'y avoir un bon signal
pour dire que les ancêtres des tétines
terre était semi aquatique
a priori les ans brito pod
on parlera de harcigny terium qui est
lent brito pote typique arsinoé terium
qui aurait aussi a des vertèbres sacré
enfin un attachement du bassin aux
vertèbres sacré qui serait assez
faiblard étant donné la taille du
bestiau ce qui pencherait aussi pour ce
qui ferait aussi penché pour un mode de
vie aquatique quoi il est il aurait
peut-être en gros il aurait peut-être eu
le cul un peu trop lourd pour pour la
pour ses jambes quoi voilà mais bon c
évidemment quand il s'agit d'animaux
éteints c'est un peu plus difficile de
de trancher alors premier groupe de tête
iter auxquelles nous allons nous
intéresser ce sont les sirènes ya donc
les du gong et les lamantins alors déjà
un petit truc un petit truc c'est que en
france
bon alors en afrikaans le moci chaos
désigne en fait les hippopotames
donc il ya beaucoup de confusion pour ce
qui est de l'identité des sirénia quand
on parle là des afrikaners en fait ils
sont pas toujours sûr de ce qu'on veut
dire quand on parle de 6 k o
parce que si chaos pour eux ça veut dire
hippopotames oui alors il appelle les
hippopotames des vaches marines jour où
vous voyez un hippopotame dans la mer
vous me téléphoner mais voilà mais on
n'est pas on n'est pas mieux en france
puisque en france on a des éléphants de
mer et on a des veaux marins donc vos
marin vaches de mer 6 k o
voyez on n'est pas beaucoup mieux parce
que le veau marin en fait c'est un
pinnipèdes donc ces basses et afoc 1
enfin cesser de la famille du phoque et
les éléphants de mer
eh ben ils sont pas du tout cousins des
éléphants se sont aussi c'est aussi des
pinnipèdes donc c'est aussi de la
famille des phoques
donc on arrête de dire que les éléphants
de mer sont des siréniens on est
d'accord que les sirénia son son marin
elles sont fortement apparentés aux
éléphants mais c'est pas des éléphants
de mer
voilà donc et le veau marin pareil c'est
pas une vache de mer tenez tenons nous
le pour dit voilà donc donc voila vous
semblerait qu'il ya beaucoup de
confusion voilà les siréniens n'ont pas
non plus inspiré le mythe des sirènes
6 il a inspiré l'autre ça c'est
certainement passer dans l'autre sens
c'est le nom de le nom sirénia qui a été
inspiré par les sirènes et pas le
contraire
bon ils ont ils ont beau avoir des
mamelles thoracique il ressemble pas
tant que ça à des sirènes qu'on ne faut
pas déconner et en plus il ne chante pas
c'est quand même la particularité des
sirènes qui n'a pas évolué pendant la
mythologie des sirènes je rappelle qu'à
la base les sirènes elle vole ce sont
des ce sont plus des oiseaux qui
ressemblent à des harpies à la base dans
la mythologie grecque
donc c'est seulement dans les
mythologies plus récente qu'elles sont
devenues semi aquatique
mais voilà la constante c'est qu'elle
chante les sirénia il chante pas
d'ailleurs pour ce qu'on en sait ils
produisent aucun son et ils sont très
mauvais pour entendre aussi en tout cas
ils n'arrivent pas entendre les bateaux
qui leur foncent dessus ça c'est sûr
donc bref il ya des études très
sérieuses un là dessus un les siréniens
sont enfin ils sont capables de les
entendre mais alors ils en ont rien à
[ __ ]
il bouge pas mais bref passons donc
comme je le disais c'est le seul groupe
d'herbivores marins les cétacés sont
tous ce carnivore ou cris lauwin planque
tony bord mais eux ils sont herbivores
il mange il mange des austères donc
c'est à dire des des herbes des alors ce
sont des graminées marine en fait les
austères donc ce ne sont pas des algues
voilà sinon je m'en remettrai je
m'emmerde aurait pas à dire austère
voilà et on a un épisode tout entier sur
les sirènes ya donc je vous invite très
fortement à aller le voir si ça vous
intéresse
voilà au niveau théologique comment
reconnaît-on à cirer n'y a bien le
le crâne des siréniens est évidemment
assez similaire à celui d'un cétacé la
narine les narines ne sont pas terminal
mais sont poussés en arrière donc bon
ils ont pas des vents ils ont une espèce
de grosses lèvres charnues et donc les
narines sont pas situés en position des
vents les narines serait situé à peu
près par la voilà donc elles sont quand
même reculer vers l'arrière ne sont pas
terminal mais du coup ça fait ressembler
le crâne un peu un crâne de cétacés à
part qu' on n'a pas de télescopage des
os du crâne les le pré maxi là le
maxillaire sont étendues vers l'arrière
comme chez les cétacés mais il ne
recouvre pas l'os frontal l'os frontal
est ici vous voyez les parcs ouverts
il est il à une suture bien-être ici
donc alors et de fait du recul du prêt
maxillaire vers l'arrière en fait vous
avez le pré maxillaire ici qui vient
toucher pardon j'ai dit l'os frontal ça
c'est l'os nasal
autant pour moi l'os frontal il est là
mais ça change rien à ce que je disais
l'os frontal
neuner pas si vous voulez n'a pas de
donné par couverts par le prêt
maxillaire il a une suture bien-être
avec le prêt maxillaire donc oui l'os
frontal et là les aux naseaux sont là et
donc vous voyez ici donc un contact
entre le pré maxillaire ici et les
offres auto ici et là donc c'est ce
qu'il a indiqué par cette flèche et ça
c'est quand même assez impressionnant
d'avoir le maxillaire qui est tellement
reculé vers l'arrière en fait qu' il va
toucher le frontal directement donc ça
c'est assez balèze après vous pouvez
voir que le jus galles et le sco mozal
au niveau de l'arcade zygomatique sont
très très épais donc pas qui est aux tic
c'est probablement lié encore une fois à
l'audition l'oreille interne l'oreille
moyenne est aussi paquet au sto tic mais
elle n'est pas détaché du crâne
donc ce qui explique peut-être pourquoi
ils entendent assez mal
et puis vous avez aussi une tendance à
l'aumône ollomo dont si donc les dents
de vienne à peu près tous les mêmes et
excepté celle du gong alors celle du
gong comme celle de lamentin ya plus de
canines
il n'y a plus que des dangers galles
donc des molaires très réduite celle du
gong d'ailleurs mais celle du gong
il ya une une paire de de défense qu'il
n'y a pas chez le lamentin donc il reste
une paire d'incisives transformer en
défense mais vous avez une tendance
générale à la réduction de la dentition
comme l'indiquent ici d'ailleurs ce
fossile de pro race tonus ici pro
rasteau musset l'un des tout premiers
siréniens et vous voyez qu'il a encore
pleines dents à l'avant de la mâchoire
donc ça tout ça ça va avoir tendance à
disparaître au cours de l'évolution des
ces tasses des siréniens est évidemment
vous avez la perte des membres
postérieurs
donc contrairement aux cétacés le coude
du membre antérieur et encore mobile
très très peu mais encore mobile et mais
par contre les membres postérieurs comme
chez les cétacés sont perdus donc ça
c'est donc ça c'est comme chez les
cétacés
je veux dire et alors une grosse
différence avec les cétacés ça va être
sur les côtes vous pouvez voir que les
cotes sont extrêmement épaisse et quand
on l'est s'ils voulaient briser si vous
trouvez des côtes brisées de
de lamentin dans le registre fossile
vous verrez qu'elles sont pas qu' au sto
tic donc elles sont très très dense et
ça c'est complètement l'opposé de ce
qu'on voit chez les cétacés donc chez
les siréniens les côtes servent de
ballasts pour maintenir la bestiole au
fond pendant qu elles broutent les
austères chez les cétacés les côtes sont
très très poreuse on dirait de l'épongé
en fait
et elles servent à stocker de la graisse
voilà donc cesser leurs réserves de
graisse aux cétacés
en plus de la grosse réserve de graisse
qu'ils ont sur la peau mais en fait la
réserve de graisse qu'ils ont sur la
peau elle sert alesi à l'isolation
thermique donc ils peuvent pas taper
dedans en cas de famine
voilà s'il tape dedans en cas de famine
c'est le dernier recours possible et ça
veut dire qu'ils vont mourir quoi parce
que toute façon ils vont perdre toute
leur chaleur et mourir d'hypothermie
donc voilà ils peuvent pas toucher à la
grèce cutanée alors ils sont obligés de
stocker de la graisse dans leur zone y
compris leurs côtes
voilà donc évidemment on va avoir la
même tendance à la perte de des membres
postérieurs chez les cétacés et chez les
siréniens donc là par exemple vous avez
sobrarbe et si rennes est alors sobrarbe
et sirènes il est magnifique il est
magique parce que c'est vraiment le
c'est vraiment un exemple de maquereaux
évolution mais tellement évident que ça
en devient dommage presque d'utiliser
l'exemple des cétacés à la place de
l'exemple des siréniens parce que
l'exemple des cétacés chez pas si vous
vous rappelez mais quand vous voulez
convaincre les gens que les cétacés ont
évolué à partir d'un mammifère terrestre
et que vous commencez l'histoire par pas
qui c'est us qui adore mais si peu à
voir avec les cétacés modernes le dire
comparez pas qui c'est us à un dauphin
ou à une baleine
bonne chance quoi comme je vous ai dit
le fil conducteur c'est vraiment la
morphologie triangulaire des dents qui a
fini par disparaître
c'est assez moderne mais pas chez leurs
ancêtres donc voilà c'est le seul fil
conducteur que vous pouvez utiliser et
la pac et ostéo sclérose de l'oreille
moyenne
donc voilà ça vous fait déjà ça vous
fait déjà beaucoup de choses qu'il faut
expliquer à votre auditoire
alors que si vous prenez les siréniens
alors là ça veut dire super simple vous
prenez le lamantin moderne voilà le
voici le lamantin moder
avec ses jambes complètement réduite et
vous prenez sobrarbe et sirènes sobrarbe
et si réd
vous comparez le crâne un lamantin
moderne vous pouvez jouer au jeu des 7
différences mais je pense je pense même
pas que vous en trouverez cette
honnêtement
voilà le pif et un poil plus gros mais
vous pouvez voir le les narines sont
déjà rétracter la forme de l'orbité et
de l'arcade le gall sont très similaires
la dentition est totalement similaires
il a déjà perdu enfin non là pour le
coup on voit encore les trous qui
correspondent à la dentition antérieures
donc ce ça devait être un peu plus comme
pro race tonus à ce niveau là mais
voilés la forme du rostre ici c'est
exactement la même
donc voilà il y est vous pouvez jouer au
jeu des trois cas de différence que vous
arrivez à trouver ce que vous en
trouverez très très peu parce que
sobrarbe et sirènes il a complètement le
crâne d'un lamentin moderne mais il a
des jambes et ça c'est beau et ça c'est
beau c'est trop beau ça d'avoir des
exemples de maquereaux évolution comme
ça là vous pouvez montrer ça aux
créationnistes le plus te b du monde à
part nié l'existence du fossile il
pourra rien faire je vais dire le même
le créationnisme ne plus te b du monde
est obligé d'admettre que sobrarbe et
sirène c'est à lamentin avec des jambes
fin de l'histoire
voilà donc évidemment il est obligé
d'inventer d'autres excuses mais par
contre il pourra pas s'échapper ils pour
il pourra pas s'échapper en vous disant
ouais pas qui s'est tu sais pas c'est
assez
voilà non là aucune échappatoire
possible
et alors bah disons que pour un
mammifère afro terre le problème des
siréniens c'est qu'on a pas beaucoup de
faux cils africain enfin si on a
beaucoup de sirénia africains à
l'oligocène on en a un certain nombre à
la fin de la scène sauf que après au
début de l'éocène et au paléo scène on a
que dalle pour vous dire les plus
anciens siréniens complet se sont
propres à ce tome ucp aux sirènes et ils
viennent en fait de jamaïque de l'éocène
inférieur de jamaïque
donc ça a longtemps été un problème
jusqu'à ce qu'on découvre quand même
quelques restes magri champ de siréniens
dans les hauts seine inférieure
d'afrique donc sept vertèbres qui es tu
vertèbres très similaires à celles de
province de mus et cette oreille interne
donc qui est très fortement paquillo sto
tic est qui qui possèdent des canots
semi circulaire réduit qui montre que
c'était un animal aquatique voilà donc
la forte pâquis ostéo sclérose de
l'oreille et la réduction des canots
semi circulaire indique un animal
aquatique
or les cétacés n'étaient pas encore
arrivés en afrique à l'époque les
cétacés à l'eocène inférieur c'est pas
qui c'est us ces ambulances et us ils
sont pas encore sorties d'inde au
pakistan donc la seule solution c'est
que ça appartiennent à un psy régnant
après on a d'autres caractères qui
pointent plus distinctement vers les
siréniens que vers les cétacés
mais qui sont un peu spécialisés je vais
pas vous sortir les caractères
maintenant donc d'autant d'autant que
j'en serai capable parce que c'est moi
qui les ai étudié pour ma thèse de ce
truc là donc voilà donc je vais pas vous
donner plus de caractère que sam si vous
si ça vous intéresse je vous enverrai le
lien pour lire ma thèse voilà donc et ça
c'est une reconstruction qui a été fait
donc par sophie qui est la voix
féminines 2 entractes science donc elle
est aussi pâle et aux artistes et donc
elle avait fait une reconstituer une
reconstruction de ce siréniens pour ma
thèse avec ses 4 belle pâte
parce que en fait basséen siréniens qui
est tout aussi primitif que pro race
tonus mais donc pour lequel on voit des
adaptations semi aquatique est aussi le
cette hausse n'a pas été trouvée dans un
milieu aquatique mais dans un dépôt
lagunaire lacustre pardon pas lagunaire
lacustre donc ils vivaient en eau douce
donc ça c'est assez balèze voilà donc
donc voilà pour le maigre registre
fossile des siréniens
des siréniens de l'éocène d'afrique donc
bon ça on peut faire mieux on peut faire
mieux mais ça veut pas dire qu'il ya pas
de 6 régnant en afrique ça veut juste
dire que à l'eocène inférieur il y en a
pas des masses
voilà mais après une fois que vous
passez à le ligoter n y en ad tetra
chier du proto sirène et on a des beaux
squelette complet c'est à ces
magnifiques et évidemment en france on
en a plein aussi puisqu'à partir du mit
à partir de l'oligocène ils sont partout
de toute façon les siréniens donc on a
dû mais taxi terium notamment en france
a montpellier on a fait le sino terium
qui a été découvert dans plein centre
ville de montpellier par exemple donc
bref des sirènes hier il y en a partout
dès que vous avez du miocène marin
généralement vous trouvez au moins des
côtes de siréniens quoi demander à
avaler aux raptor puis il avait fait une
des villas fait des vidéos d'ailleurs je
me rappelle d'une vidéo sa vidéo sur
falling kingdom qui s'appelle fallen
kingdom sa critique de fallen king
domicile et dans les carrières en train
de fouiller et puis ils trouvent ils
trouvent un morceau de crâne de
siréniens donc voilà c'est il était
extrêmement commun en réalité donc la
diversité moderne ne reflète pas du tout
la grande diversité passer d'aidé
siréniens aujourd'hui c'est assez
désespérant mais si vous voulez en
savoir plus encore une fois aller voir
ma vidéo sur les syriens le l'épisode
d'entracte science sur les six règne à
l'époque où on s'appelait encore cette
option donc pour aujourd'hui on va se
contenter de décrire les deux familles
de siréniens d'aujourd'hui les deux
familles donc qu'ils se sont séparés au
courant de l'oligocène donc ces deux
familles ce sont les dugongs d'idées à
gauche et les tricks équidés à droite
donc les du gong et les lamantins donc
comment distinguer ces deux familles
déjà la forme du crâne les dugongs un
rostre fortement tordu vers le bas alors
que les alors que les lamantins ou un
crâne qui est quasiment droit les
lamantins n'ont pas de défense les
dugongs des défenses mâles et femelles
ont des défenses d'ailleurs les femelles
plus petit mais
deux ans non la dentition est très
différente les du gong ont des dents
relictuelle quasiment qu'il n'utilise
quasiment pas donc voilà les trois
petites dents trop petite dans
résiduelles qui reste celle du gong
alors que les tricks équidés donc les
lamantins ils ont un renouvellement
dentaire continue d'arrière vers l'avant
donc ils ont un tapis roulant dentaire
qui se renouvelle tout au long de leur
vie donc vous avez des molaires à
l'infini on vous avez munitions de
molaire à l'infini chez chez les
lamantins ça ressemble un peu à ce qu'on
voit chez les éléphants sauf que les
éléphants eux le tapis roulant fini par
s'arrêter au bout d'un moment la
dernière mais leur sort est derrière y'a
plus rien qui vient ça ça n'arrive pas
chez les lamantins et c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont balèzes les lamantins jamais
ils sont à court de munitions toute leur
vie ils vont produire des molaires et
enfin si si vous n'avez pas accès au
crâne si vous voyez un lamantin vivant
comment arrivez-vous à le reconnaître et
bien tout simplement en regardant la que
les lamantins ont une queue en forme de
pelles les du gong ont une queue
semblable à celle d'un dauphin
voilà comment on reconnaît alain mantin
d'un du gong mieux et puis alors oui je
n'étais pas sûr de la m celle là mais il
ya un petit groupe là un petit groupe de
mammifères qui a vécu à l'oligocène et
au mit en scène uniquement et qui qui
s'appelle les desnos chilien et qui
ressemble assez superficiellement au
siréniens alors ce sont des mammifères
semi aquatique qui ont la particularité
d'avoir les pattes en posture semi érigé
ça rappelle un peu d'ailleurs la posture
d'un ornithorynque donc la posture semi
ériger des pattes d'un ornithorynque est
bon à part que les ornithorynques ont
une si vous regardez la région là autour
du cou les ornithorynques ont une énorme
ceinture pectoral alors que alors que là
vous voyez il n'y a pas de ceinture
pectoral c'est un onglet donc il ya qu
une omoplate il n'y a pas de clavicule
on en a parlé les ongulés n'ont pas de
clavicule donc il ya que les omoplates
et vous avez directement les membres
mais sinon ça ressemble à un
ornithorynque bon après ça ressemble pas
un ornithorynque au niveau de la taille
au niveau de la taille ça ressemble plus
à une vache
voilà un hippopotame d'ailleurs vous
voyez là c'est réponse ici les
reconstituer comme un hippopotame parce
que justement comme l'hippopotame il a
des grosses défenses des incisives en
forme de défense et puis vous voyez
l'insertion d'un muscle ici des lèvres
qui est énorme c'est pour ça qu'il est
reconstruit aussi avec ses lèvres très
charnue donc un mix entre un hippopotame
finalement et ainsi régnant et comme les
siréniens vous voyez il ya un rostre
avec un rostre qui ressemble un peu à
celui du lamentin avec les narines à peu
rétracté mais contrairement aux
siréniens par contre les dents ont rien
à voir
les dents sont même pas l'eau fond dont
on fait les dents sont vous voyez les 4
q speed protocole par akon meta konipo
caunes les 4 q speed principales qui
sont flanqués de cul speed latéral est
en fait qui forment des tonneaux d'émail
avec du ces de la dentine à l'intérieur
quoi donc ça c'est une dentition qui est
complètement unique on sait pas du tout
du tout d'où ça sort et la vérité c'est
que ben j'aimerais bien pouvoir vous
dire que les dix mots stylia sont
effectivement les cousins des siréniens
mais la vérité c'est qu'on n'en sait
rien comme je les dis le le rostre
ressemble à un sirénia le bord
antérieure de l'orbité est effectivement
en ligne avec le bord antérieures de la
rangée dentaires ce qui ressemble aussi
aux siréniens voilà l'orbité est un peu
situé vers l'avant vous avez le trou
auditif externe qui est effectivement à
l'intérieur du crâne et pas sur le bord
inférieur du crâne donc tout ça ça
pointerait vers le fait de placer les
desnos chilien parmi les pennons gueulé
oui mais le problème c'est que déjà
comme je le disais ils ont pas la
morphologie lofo d'hondt des dents ils
n'ont pas non plus l'organisation tax et
au pod des doigts aulas et là on est en
bas on est retour en mode puzelat il
n'ya pas d'alignement voyez que le cette
hausse l'a donc le nul n'a est aligné
certes avec celui-là mais celui là après
il est aligné avec deux doigts
au lieu d'un seul que celui là il est il
est plus que ce carpien là il est pas du
tout aligner avec aucun des deux radios
sous ilna
donc voilà vous avez des eaux vous avez
cette hausse là qui est aligné avec
cette hausse là vous avez cette hausse
lac est aligné avec ce douala mais
au-delà de ça il n'y a pas vraiment de
taxer au pot divisible donc ça c'est un
premier problème et le problème
principal qu'on a avec les desmo stidia
c'est que pour autant qu'on sache on les
a jamais trouvé ailleurs que autour du
pacifique
donc là vous avez l'amérique du nord
vous avez l'asie et voici le registre
fossile complet d'aidé smos chilien
oligocène et miocène strictement et
voilà on les a jamais trouvé ailleurs
que là et maintenant il ya des files au
génie qui qui aurait tendance à placer
les desnos chilien en fait parmi les
paieries sow dactyle alors ce qui résout
le problème géographique par rapport au
paiement güller je veux dire du coup on
n'est pas obligé de dire qu'il y avait
un pédoncule et ailleurs qu'en afrique
mais par contre ça fout le bordel du
côté des périseaux dactyle parce que
voyez la main elle n'est pas plus
périlleux enfin les pieds les pieds et
les mains sont pas péri sous dactyle du
tout sont pas sont pas du tout mais ac
sonic donc point d'interrogation sur les
death most îliens fallait bien que je
les mette quelque part voilà débrouillez
vous donc on repart sur un territoire
confirmé un territoire confirmé les
ambri topol ben je dit et iter confirmé
mais évidemment comme les ans brito
potes sont complètement état c'est un
groupe qui sait état au début du miocène
donc encore une fois quand les a reçus
au tactile et les périodes acte ils sont
passés en
en afrique les ans brito pod n'ont pas
tenu la concurrence et se sont éteints
vous imaginez bien que quand on semble à
ce point rhinocéros en même temps des
quand il ya des vrais rhinocéros qui
arrive on est un peu emmerdé non ils
auraient pu gagner il aurait pu gagner
mais ils avaient les mêmes chances il
avait l'avantagé du terrain mais non
c'est pas comme ça que ça s'est produit
voilà donc les ans brito potes ce sont
des gros animaux ils n'ont pas toujours
ressemblé à des rhinocéros évidemment
arsinoé terium est un cas extrême mais
il n'y a que les ars i know it et rider
c'est à dire les proches parents
d'arsinoé terium qui parmi les ans brito
por ressembler à ce point des rhinocéros
mais ils ont tous des caractères en
commun saison brito pod
ils sont généralement de taille moyenne
à très grosse ils ont une morphologie
dentaire à lampes de doute ce qui veut
dire que quand vous regardez les dents
en vue occlusale vous avez un w tac
donc ouais bon là c'est pas génial
génial mais ici sur celui là vous voyez
bien le w lapine pim pim pim voilà pim
pim pim pim donc morphologie dentaire en
forme de w donc celles au fond dos lalo
faudon si ancestrale qui a évolué vers
une alarme dodo si on avait vu ça avec
les brotteaux terres déjà d'ailleurs
donc là c'est un groupe strictement
africain qu'il l'a fait et on s'est
quand même temps à l'eocène et à
l'oligocène en amérique du nord il ya un
autre groupe qui évolue de façon
totalement convergente avec les
rhinocéros et qui lui aussi évolué va
acquérir une dentition à l'amp dos
don'ts
donc c'est assez fascinant en fait les
histoires de convergence évolutive chez
les mammifères là c'est fascinant parce
que ni l'un ni l'autre ne sont de vrais
rhinocéros mais pourtant il se ressemble
vachement et ils ne sont même pas
apparentés en tout cas pas plus que le
son le reste des mammifères quoi
l'ancêtre commun de ces deux trucs là à
la basse et un petit machin qui
ressemble à une musaraigne c5 et c'est
ça qui est formidable quoi donc ya pas
de diastème les molaires les prémolaires
sont
sont fortement mot la risée une fois de
plus pas de diastème ça veut dire qu'il
ya pas de creux en fait entre les
incisives et les canines
d'ailleurs vous pouvez voir que les
canines
là pour le coup sont transformés en elle
somme la réforme
et là il ya même il ya même la troisième
à sisyphe qui est mollahs reform donc il
n'y a pas de défense il ya rien tout et
tout est balancé dans la mastication car
en fait tout tout est utile tout est
balancé dans la mastication
c'est assez balèze et donc la forme la
plus connue c'est évidemment arsinoé
therion avec ses deux grosses cornes
latéral
donc des vraies cornes alors des vraies
cornes peut-être pas en fait parce
qu'elles ont elles ressemblent plus à
des hausses icône
d'ailleurs vous voyez il ya des petits
aussi conne à l'arrière donc ça
ressemble plus à des hausses icône parce
qu'elle était recouverte de peau la
texture en fait qu'on voit sur les sur
ses cornes indique qu'elle était
recouverte de peau et pas vraiment de
kératine et surtout elles sont creuses
donc elles sont complètement conne et
voyez le nez s'ouvre là est en fait les
sinus vont à l'intérieur directement en
fait donc elles sont complètement
creuses et elle servait probablement à
l'animal à produire des infrasons donc
c'était une grosse caisse de résonance
on le sait parce que encore une fois
pour ma thèse j'ai pu étudier son
oreille mais l'oreille interne est
fortement adapté à l'audition des basses
fréquences donc
donc c'est très très très probable que
c'est que ses cordes étaient en fait
utilisé pour produire des infrasons
voilà ah oui on représente souvent
arsinoé terium avec une trompe une
petite troupe de tapir c'est dû au fait
que déjà vous voyez les narines sont pas
terminal les narines devrait se trouver
là si elle était terminale et elles ne
le sont pas le sont légèrement rétracter
et cette surface ici du coup la surface
ainsi dégagées par les narines rétracter
certes de d'insertion à un gros muscles
donc le gros muscles des lèvres comme
chez les tapirs est ici vous pouvez bien
avoir la fosse en fait du muscle des
lèvres donc cina alors je sais pas si ça
allait jusqu'à former une trompe mais il
avait au moins des grosses lèvres
voilà des grosses lèvres mobiles comme
les rhinocéros la très très très très
flexible et alors pareil on avait un
problème avec le registre fossile des
ambrits tôt potes c'est que on en a
beaucoup en afrique à l'oligocène on en
a quelques-uns en afrique à l'eocène
vous voyez en violet ici mais on en a
aussi en europe à l'eocène est alors
quand on va jusqu'au paléocène en
réalité on les trouve qu'exclusivement
en asie et en turquie or ça c'est plus
trop vraiment
c'est plus trop vraiment de l'africa est
là on était un peu embêté on était
presque prêt d'ailleurs à dire que les
en briques open n'était peut-être pas
des dp nom du lait parce que pas
africain d'origine et que pour être un
pédoncule et il faut être un afro terre
et c'est quand même plus pratique d'être
africain mais heureusement l'année
dernière a été découvert alors quand je
dis l'année n'ont pas l'année dernière
il ya deux ans donc en 2000 en 2018 a
été découvert en 2017 pardon bon art
vérifier quoi dans ces eaux là il ya
très il n'y a pas très longtemps a été
découvert style all of us donc c'est un
petit mammifère 2
du paléocène du maroc donc qui est à peu
près aussi vieux que au cpa
sauf que regarder il à ting ting ting
ting d'abeilles ou label morphologie
zalando d'hondt
[Musique]
ddd en brito pod
donc c'est comme un art si nos hits r
mais la morpho le mais les dents sont
pas ipso dont donc là on voit très très
bien le w contrairement à harcigny
terium tout à l'heure on ne voyait pas
super bien avec le w chez arsinoé terium
ena matériaux mais quand même bien usés
il ya une forte usure parce qu'ils sont
ipso dont tu là on a eu des dents on a
des dents bracchi dont tu es qui sont
fortement la langue de dante
donc il n'y a pas vraiment de doute sur
le fait que que stylo dofus est 1-1 et
un an brito pod et du coup il est aussi
ancien que fenaco l'opus est la forme
qui est retrouvé en turquie donc bon ça
ça ramène pas totalement la racine du
groupe en afrique mais disons que ça ça
nourrit le débat sur toi ton considérer
les ambri taupe au doux nom quand de
l'épée longue il est comme gelée dit le
groupe c et al oligocène on aura jamais
de l'adn donc ça se base c'est que à la
morphologie ma gueule et comme on le
sait en mammifères au logis la
morphologie
ça marche pas toujours super bien
et enfin last but not least le groupe le
plus diversifié de tout l'été tit r les
proboscidiens avec rien de moins que 250
espèces fossiles décrite à ce jour et
250 je le dis à la louche parce qu'en
réalité tous les jours y en a des
nouvelles là je vais dire si vous avez
l'impression que les gens publient des
nouvelles espèces de dinosaures chinois
tous les deux semaines sachez qu'au
niveau des proboscidiens
on défonce la moyenne systématiquement
le dire il ya encore cinq ans j'aurais
annoncé 180 espèces et maintenant faut
en annonces et 250 et même là encore il
faudrait que je revérifie si ça se
trouve on est peut-être plus près de 280
maintenant mais bref donc voilà vous
pouvez aller vérifier vous même sur
paléobiologie data base vous marquez
proboscidiens et vous regardez le
chiffre que le truc vous sort vous allez
déguster
voilà donc 250 espèces fossiles
aujourd'hui il en reste deux ou trois
donc c'est vous dire le programme qu'on
s'apprête à attaquer un niveau palais au
paléo proboscidiens au logis donc
attachez vos ceintures allez vous
préparer un café pause pipi pause clope
et on y va donc comment reconnaît-on un
éléphant aujourd'hui c'est très simple
les incisives sont transformés en
défense donc comment sait-on que les
défenses sont des incisives parce que
bon il c'est pas comme si il avait plein
dedans pour comparer les éléphants et
bien tout simplement parce que les
défenses sont acérés ici dans les eaux
près maxillaire or les seuls dans qu'on
trouve dans les eaux près maxillaire ce
sont les défenses on a aussi une
rétraction des narines
donc ne nous y trompons pas ceci n'est
pas la qualité pour l'oeil ceci n'est
pas lors beats et la cavité pour les
narines l'oeil se trouve là sur le côté
du crâne
là où il est censé être donc ça c'est la
qualité des narines
d'ailleurs vous n'êtes certainement pas
sans savoir que le mythe des cyclopes
vient probablement de quelques
explorateurs grecs qui ont découvert des
feux des élèves des crânes d'éléphants
fossilisés et qui ont pris cette cavité
justement pour l'oeil pour un oeil
unique et médian mais bref je digresse
et on a et j'ai une diapo dédié à sa
déjà
donc voilà ceci n'est pas l'oeil ceci
est la narine et l'oeil se trouve ici et
vous avez donc une rétraction des
narines avec une fausse ici pour le
muscle des lèvres pour les muscles des
lèvre supérieure une fosse qui se
prolongent aussi sur le côté
bref vous avez une énorme trompe mais ça
évidemment je ne vous a
je ne vous apprends rien avec cela mais
voilà ça la présence de cette troupe se
reflète sur le crâne grâce à sa grâce à
cette grosse fausse ici vous avez
évidemment des dents molaires
extrêmement gros ça je voulais dire les
dents adultes pèsent entre 2 et 5 kg et
en fait c'est dedans
les éléphants n'ont qu'une seule dans
par demi mâchoire à la fois donc il ya
qu une seule dent qui est fonctionnel à
la fois vous voyez une dent ici une dent
ici et puis vous avez imaginé une dent
ou une dent à gauche il dans la droite
est en fait c'est parce que ses dents
sont tellement grosses en fait il vous
pouvaient ils ne peuvent en avoir qu'une
seule à la fois et du coup elle se
renouvelle non pas horizontalement non
pas verticalement c'est-à-dire de base
en haut où de haut en bas mais d'arrière
en avant
donc ça forme un tapis roulant ici vous
voyez donc la dent rouge qui est donc la
première prémolaires est sorti puis à
les pousser vers l'avant par la jaune
la jaune est elle même poussé par vers
l'avant par la bleu bleu qui est elle
même poussé vers l'avant par la verte et
vous voyez l'oranje sortir derrière qui
est là dans adultes finale qui est
pousse vers l'avant
la dent verte donc vous avez est en fait
le compte de prémolaires est assez
similaire le compte de molaires et
prémolaires est assez similaire à un
autre au final donc vous avez une
molaire la orange deux molaires la verte
3 molaires la bleue et puis vous avez
une prémolaires 2 prémolaires est alors
devant vous avez une troisième
prémolaires qui est marron ici et qu'on
voit sur le schéma ici donc vous avez
une petite prémolaires marron deux
autres prémolaires la rouge la jaune et
après vous avez trois mots l'air donc ça
c'est bon nous on n'a que deux
prémolaires mais voilà vous avez un
compte deux molaires et prémolaires qui
est assez similaire à celles des humains
bon je sais pas non pas que ça veut dire
quoi que ce soit mais c'est juste que ça
revient à ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure que une fois que la troisième
molaire l'a fini de bouger vers l'avant
eh ben c'est fini générique de fin il y
aura plus rien qui viendra après et ça
et ça c'est la grande malédiction des
éléphants c'est la grande malédiction
des éléphants parce que une fois qu'ils
sont une fois que la dernière dent est
tombé eh ben ils meurent d'inanition ils
n'ont pas vraiment d'autre choix et donc
et vous vous rappelez donc cette
morphologie en lamelles très
caractéristique et bien elle est liée
aussi à ce renouvellement dentaire
puisque en fait les dents ne tombe pas
d'un coup en avant elle tombe une
lamelle à la fois donc là vous voyez la
dent bleue elle est normalement plus
grande que ça mais les lamelles sont
tombées les unes après les autres et là
il reste encore deux trois labels avant
qu'elle tombe donc tout ça c'est tout ça
s'est connecté tout ça c'est c'est un
grand réseau de caractère qui ont tous
probablement qu évolué en même temps et
aussi qui a probablement échos évolué
avec les dents mais a aussi avec la
trompe c'est la pneumatique à sion du
crâne
là ce que vous voyez c'est un crâne
d'éléphant ou en fait l'extérieur a été
complètement érodé donc vous avez accès
aux sinus donc là vous avez l'entrée des
naseaux et à l'intérieur il ya des sinus
et toussa toussa toussa toussa c'est les
sinus parra naseaux et vous voyez que
les sinus parana zoo ils s'arrêtent pas
aux à l'os nasal qui est ici ils
s'étendent dans le frontal dans le
pariétal dans l'occiput al même dans le
square aux halles dans le jeu galles
enfin il y en a partout
il y en a partout du sinus cela rend le
crâne des éléphants ultra-léger le crâne
des éléphants et règle est très gros
mais dans l'absolu mais il ne pèse pas
plus que deux ou trois kilos mais ça ça
va de pair justement avec le fait que
les dents elle en tout si vous imaginez
si vous avez 4 dans 2 3 kilos ça vous
fait 12 kg tish plus le poids de la
trompe qui peut peser jusqu'à il me
semble
20 30 ou 40 kilos un truc comme ça quoi
donc d'imaginer déjà le poids de la tête
sans ça donc voilà la pneumatique nation
ça compense un peu au moins ça permet de
compenser un peu le poids de la tête
donc voilà une autre façon de
représenter le renouvellement dentaire
qui est peut-être un peu plus graphique
peut-être un poil moins justes mais un
peu plus graphique et là vous voyez donc
les lamelles des dents et la façon dont
elle c'est rod donc vous voyez que les
lamelles elle commence pas comme des
lamelles à la base les lofts sont en
fait composé de plats de petit cul cul
speed alignées les unes avec les autres
un peu ce qu'on voyait aussi chez le
lamantin d'ailleurs donc c'est une fois
qu'ils sont usés convoi des baux l'ofs
voilà alors comment on fait la
différence entre un éléphant d'asie un
éléphant d'afrique vous avez cinq
minutes non je déconne je vais vous le
dire mais vous le savez probablement
déjà donc on regarde les oreilles si
c'est des grandes oreilles c'est un
éléphant d'afrique si elles sont petites
cette année les fantasy vous regarder
les défenses si elles sont petites c'est
un éléphant d'asie si elles sont grandes
cette année les enfants d'afrique vous
regardez la forme de la trompe aussi si
vous avez deux doigts sur la trompe
c'est un éléphant d'afrique si vous
n'avez qu'un seul doigt sur le dessus de
la trompe c'est un éléphant d'asie
si vous avez si vous avez une bosse une
grosse bosse voyez sur le dos vous êtes
face à un éléphant d'afrique si vous
avez un d'eau relativement dont vous
êtes face à un éléphant d'asie si vous
avez un dos et les faits relativement
droit c'est un éléphant d'afrique
mais évidemment je vous connais
paléontologues que vous êtes comment à
huy est le nombre de doigts aussi si
vous avez 4 4 ou 5 doigts à l'avant et
trois à l'arrière c'est un éléphant
d'afrique s'il y en a 5 à l'avant et
quatre à l'arrière
c'est un éléphant d'asie voilà ils ont
même pas le même nombre de doigts en
plus et évidemment les paléontologues
savoir ce qui se passe sur les dents
parce qu'un bon palet au mama logist
regarde regarde tout de suite les dents
et bien sûr les dents l'éléphant
d'afrique à moins de l'offre que
l'éléphant d'asie dans le voyait
l'éléphant d'asie a plein de petits lov
et 3 alors que l'éléphant d'afrique à
quelques gros l'ofs beaucoup moins
nombreux et vous avez cette forme un peu
de
diamant au milieu aussi donc il
s'appelle le pli loxodonta et qui donne
son nom au genre de l'éléphant d'afrique
loxodonta le genre et les faces étant
réservé à l'éléphant d'asie
voilà tout est maintenant c'est parti
pour l'histoire évolutive des éléphants
là on va se régaler les gars parce que
ça va prendre des heures non je déconne
je déconne j'ai essayé de raccourcir sa
le plus possible mais de fait je vais
devoir passer sur beaucoup de choses et
ça c'est dommage mais je vous renvoie
vers la vidéo de sim plex paléo sur
laquelle j'ai collaboré
on a donc je dis et je les ai d un peu à
écrire l'épisode sur les éléphants en
fait les deux épisodes les trois
épisodes sur les éléphants
donc il a fait trois épisodes sur les
éléphants s'il vous plaît que ce paléo
que je les ai aidé à écrire
donc voilà j'ai jamais eu le courage de
faire une vidéo sur l'évolution des
éléphants parce que c'est un sujet
tellement énorme
et même là je même là je vais vous faire
un cours sur l'évolution des éléphants
je suis pas complètement satisfait de ce
que je vais vous dire parce que je
trouve que j'en passe beaucoup juste
pour pouvoir rendre sa digest
l'évolution des éléphants je vous ai dit
c'est 250 espèces c'est impossible
d'être exhaustif sans prendre des heures
et des heures et des heures et des
heures
donc voilà je suis là j'estime qu'il
reste une demi heure quarante cinq
minutes je peux pas faire le tour de
tous voilà vous avez une histoire qui
commence dès le paléo scène avec hérité
rien mais vous voyez vous voyez à quel
point les espèces sont resserrées les
unes des autres
il ya quasiment pas de gap dans
l'évolution des éléphants c'est
formidable enfin dans l'évolution des
proboscidiens donc voilà allez voir si
vous voulez en savoir plus allez voir
les vidéos de sim plex paléo
elles sont très complètes elles sont
très bien faites et vous y apprendrez si
vous si vous êtes capable d'en revenir
et de me les réciter par coeur alors là
éventuellement j'envisagerai de faire
moi même une vidéo dessus mais ça
n'arrivera pas ça n'arrivera pas donc
l'histoire des éléphants on va la
diviser basiquement on va la diviser
basiquement en trois parties les
éléphants les proboscidiens bazot les
mastodontes et les et les formes
modernes
voilà ça va être ça l'idée donc les
proboscidiens bazzo une histoire qui
commence au paléo scène qui va s'arrêter
alami oligocène avec des petites
prolongation tiré pendant le milieu
scène parler des notaires idée que qui
sont pas vraiment des éléphants bazzo
mais il fallait bien les mettre quelque
part
et puis vous avez après les mastodontes
une histoire qui commence à la ligue
hossein voire même à la fin de l'éocène
et se prolonge jusqu'à l'extinction des
mammouths idée il ya dix mille ans et
vous avez les éléphantes idées qui sont
finalement les seuls survivants
aujourd'hui donc les éléphantes idées
dans lequel on inclut des fois lester
godon idée ou pas donc si on inclut les
stés god haute idée dans les éléphantes
idée ça fait lester godon ine mais voilà
bon moi je vais pas les inclure parce
que la morphologie de leurs dents est
grosso modo lé mastodonte voilà le
mastodonte c'est ça réfère à une
morphologie dentaire d'ailleurs ça ne
réfère pas tellement à un groupe k un
groupe de promo cydia avec une
morphologie dentaires assez similaire
voilà mais on va voir tout ça dans le
détail
et ça commence maintenant commençons
donc par les proboscidiens bazot donc
les proboscidiens bazzo les plus anciens
comme je les dis date du paléocène il
s'agit d' eritherium qui est très
fragmentaire donc je préfère vous
montrez phosphates et riaume son plus
proche cousin on va dire mais qui date
lui de l'éocène donc les premiers
proboscidiens on aurait eu vraiment des
difficultés très très prononcé les
identifiés comme étant des proboscidiens
enfin des proches parents des éléphants
si on avait vécu à l'époque parce que
ben comme vous montre cette
reconstruction
d'une part ils étaient de petite taille
eritherium le crâne tiens
aurait tenu dans la main je veux dire
donc on est sur un animal qui est plutôt
sur un animal qui est plutôt de la
taille d'un renard voire même plus petit
que ça presque d'un presque d'un
d'amande ailleurs d'un gros lapin on va
dire voilà phosphates et riaume était
peut-être un peu plus gros de la taille
éventuellement d'un bon gros chien voilà
donc là vous avez une reconstitution de
phosphates et riaume donc il a
reconstruit avec des poils parce qu'il
est de petite taille et que l'on sait
que chez les éléphants moderne l'absence
de poils et directement dus au fait
qu'il soit grand massif donc ils n'ont
pas besoin de fourrure pour ce pour être
chaud voilà il est reconstituée avec des
petites oreilles parce qu'encore une
fois les grandes oreilles des éléphants
d'afrique c'est un problème de
thermorégulation donc s'il ya pas beau
je veux dire ils risquent pas d'avoir
trop chaud en étant de petite taille
donc petites oreilles on n'a pas de
trompe parce que les narines son
terminal chez phosphates et riaume si
vous regardez ici un autre un autre
proboscidiens bases au mali terium vous
verrez que les narines sont aussi
terminal légèrement plus rétracter chez
moe eritherium mois eritherium est déjà
un poil plus engagés dans la rétraction
des narines mais globalement elles sont
sur le bout du nez avec une lèvre du
coup assez mobile parce que comme comme
phosphate herriot mémo hérite pardon
comme mot eritherium phosphates et
riaume à une fausse ici sur le côté
voilà du sur le côté du maxillaire pour
l'insertion d'une lèvre mobile donc
voilà que vous voyez ici donc une lèvre
une lèvre un peu charnière un peu mobile
capable d'attraper les choses voilà
d'une certaine dextérité et du coup ce
qui va le connecter aux éléphants et
bien ça va être sa dentition donc la
dentition de fausses matériaux mais
typiquement celle d'un paiement du lait
dont vous voyez lofo d'hondt très
fortement lofo dont vous voyez des
prémolaires et des molaires l'a donc
fortement lofo d'onde comme un péno
gueuler mais fausse materion en plus
ceci pour lui qu'il a des incisives
fortement développés et notamment les
biens la deuxième paire d'incisives duo
est la première paire d'incisives du bas
et ça on sait grâce aux mastodontes qui
ont deux paires de défense une paire de
défense sur la mâchoire supérieure une
paire de défense sur la mâchoire
inférieure donc les mastodontes du
miocène qu'on verra un peu plus loin
c'est grâce à eux que ces sont les
incisives supérieures du la deuxième
période incisives supérieures du et la
première paire d'incisives inférieur qui
vont devenir les défenses donc fausse
matériaux mais déjà engagée dans le
développement des défenses même si pour
le coup on voit pas encore que ce sont
des défenses elles ont même encore de
les maïs et ses incisives
c'est ce que vous voyez ici chez moi
eritherium mais vous voyez chez moi
eritherium il ya même les incisives
inférieurs sont devenues encore plus pro
clive et les assises supérieur sont
encore plus développée donc nos
eritherium est un peu plus d arriver
parce qu'il a des incisives qui sont un
peu plus gros c'est un peu plus engagée
dans la voie pour devenir des défenses
voilà et on a déjà un début de réduction
des canines donc les canines qui sont
complètement absentes g chez les
éléphants les défenses ne sont pas
faites par les canines chez les
éléphants contrairement aux phacochères
voilà donc ça c'est les proboscidiens
bazzo des proboscidiens donc on aurait
probablement pas reconnus comme des
proches parents des éléphants donc
probablement les aurait pris pour des
tapirs ou des choses comme ça voilà donc
mon eritherium c'est vraiment le propos
cydia un basalte hippiques parce que
c'est un des premiers qui a été
découvert il a été découvert au début du
siècle dernier
il est à vous voyez qu'il est un peu
plus gros que phosphate terium là on est
plus sur un animal qui est qui et même
un peu plus massifs qu'à tapir pas
encore de la taille d'un
un hippopotame quoi mais mettrait
hippopotame est ce qu dans l'aspect
général de l'animal je vous ai montré
une image tout à l'heure avec des
narines comme je le disais globalement
terminal mais un peu rétracté ce qui
fait qu'il avait probablement une trompe
voilà donc avec une trompe qui est saint
céré ici sous l'arcade zygomatique et
hop développer ici à un peu
d'attachement ici sous justement le
[Musique]
l'espace laissé par la part la petite
rétraction de la narine mais comme je
les dis la rétraction de la narine et
pacy développé que ça on a une perte de
la première prémolaires alors je sais
pas si vous vous rappelez mais dans la
séquence de remplacement des éléphants
2d dans des éléphants y avait pas de
prémolaires donc là les restes résumé
une fois de plus ici mohler molaires 3
molaires deux molaires un prémolaires 2
prémolaires 4 3 2 mais pas un
voilà donc 4 3 2 mais pas de prémolaires
une donc voilà c'est la perte de la
prémolaires une sécher mot eritherium
qu'elle arrive et elle va être conservés
du coup enfin cette perte va être va se
perpétuer jusqu aux éléphants moderne ça
va participer à leur malédiction parce
qu'une paire à une prémière de plus ça
aurait quand même été pas du luxe quoi
donc voilà les les prémolaires commence
à ce mot la risée chez moe eritherium
aussi donc les
vous avez des trois molières ici et les
prémolaires commence à devenir un peu
plus molle à reform vous voyez que les
les prémolaires de mots eritherium sont
pas du tout mollahs reform il ya qu un
seul nov
donc chez moe eritherium voiliers de
l'ofs sur les prémolaires au moins les
deux dernières donc moi eritherium c'est
vraiment le propos sidéens basale
archétypale mais c'est paradoxalement
aussi le plus dérivés si vous regardez
7,7 phylogénie voyez les proboscidiens
bazzo sont ici ils ont été mis de côté
graphiquement pour qu'on puisse les
biens les isoler maury terium c'est plus
dérivés c'est celui qui a vécu le plus
tard aussi donc à la fin de l'éocène et
au début de l'oligocène et voyez bande à
part à part le fait qu'il soit un peu
plus gros et qui les narines un peu plus
rétracter c'est vrai qu'il est de
manière générale il est très semblable à
tous les autres quoi à part comme je le
disais au niveau de la taille
donc maintenant on passe aux éléphants
ti forme on va parler des mastodontes
donc les mastodontes qui sont les
éléphants ti formes les plus bazot mais
le mais évidemment dans des éléphants
qui forment on compte aussi les
éléphants les vrais alors les
mastodontes sont un peu plus proche des
éléphants moderne pour plusieurs raisons
la première c'est que déjà séché les
mastodontes que les éléphants que les
proboscidiens vont évoluer pour la
première fois une grande taille donc
d'une taille qu'on considérait comme
moyenne à hatay très très grande
l'un des plus anciens donc fille mia
enfin fio mia et paléo mastodonte qui
sont parmi les mastodontes les plus
anciens faisait déjà la taille la taille
d'un hippopotame au moins voire d'un
rhinocéros quoi c'était déjà des gros
animaux et ses élèves à ces mastodontes
ils vont à barr donc comme je le disais
plusieurs caractères en commun avec les
éléphants moderne
la première c'est de là que vient leur
nom c'est la mastodonte si mastodonte
aussi qui vient du fait qu'en fait les
culs speed chez les ch et les
mastodontes sont sont très pointus et
ressemblent un peu à des mamelons en
fait donc c'est de là que via le terme
mastodonte des dents en forme de
mamelons et ses mamelons en fait ils
vont être alignés en l'ofs
donc comme chez un péno gueuler comme
comme c'est censé être le cas chez les
paiements gueulé mais c'est chez les
mastodontes qu'on va avoir une
multiplication du nombre de l'ofs
donc ici vous voyez par exemple chez
palais au mastodonte il n'y a pas deux
lobes seulement il y en a 1 2 3 sur les
molaires donc 3,9 sur les molaires et
vous voyez la dernière molaires qui est
prête à sortir ici il y a un deux trois
et même un petit quatrième l'oeuf qui
commencent à sortir donc on a au moins
trois l'ofs
et donc ça et ça ça veut dire quelque
chose d'important ça veut dire que le
mécanisme qui va conduire à la
multiplication du nombre de l'ofs là
vous avez un exemple annonce qu st
mastodonte c'est probablement à des
mastodontes les plus répandues dans le
monde adam cus on en trouve aussi en
france à montpellier par exemple donc un
an cus
il a vécu au pliocène et vous voyez la
multiplication des l'ofs
donc les dents sont toujours mastodontes
mais vous avez une multiplication des
l'offre l'aïe en a 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 et donc
voilà il ya un mécanisme génétique qui
s'est déverrouillé chez ces éléphantes y
forme bazzo qui a conduit à l'évolution
de l'accroissement du nombre de l'ofs
en réalité et donc ça pour la première
fois ça se déverrouille chez les
mastodontes donc c'est un caractère très
important c'est sané call of de plus
pour mastodonte pour paléo mastodonte
mais c'est un grand pas sur l'évolution
des proboscidiens et donc les
mastodontes sont aussi les premiers à
avoir des défenses vrai donc des
défenses sans émail et donc pas les au
mastodonte vous pouvez voir il avait une
paire de défense en eau est aussi une
paire de défense en bas qui sont
directement dérivés des incisives de la
deuxième paire d'incisives supérieur et
de la première perdent incisif inférieur
chez les proboscidiens bazot évidemment
vous avez aussi l'apparition de la
trompe la trompe qui est finalement le
caractère signature des éléphants
d'aujourd'hui la trompe apparaît pour la
première fois chez les mastodontes chez
qui donc là on a une vraie rétraction
bien prononcé de des narines et surtout
une narine de très grande taille voyez
que ces mots eritherium vous avez une
petite ouverture là la narine et très
très grande donc une grosse insertion de
pour la pour le pour la trompe donc
après ils ont quand même des caractères
plus tôt primitif les dents sont
toujours bras qui donc chez les
mastodontes dont vous n'avez pas encore
l'usure des lofts qui va donner cette
l'usure des culs speed qui va donner les
lofts qu'on voit chez les éléphants
moderne donc les dents sont toujours
bracchi d'hondt et donc vous allez avoir
finalement des tendances évolutives
assez assez évidente sur l'évolution des
dents on va commencer par des animaux
avec 3 nov
voilà comme fille au mien et paléo
mastodonte et puis vous allez avoir
développement en parallèle des fois
enfin progressif vers la lignée des
éléphants mais aussi avec des
développements parallèle du nombre de
l'ofs donc d'abord on va avoir les tris
lofo dont tu donc ce qu'on appelle les
gonfle au tertre îlots faut donc puis
vous allez avoir les gauff hauteur avec
4 love donc légaux faut taire tetra lofo
d'hondt
et puis vous allez avoir les stés golo
faut donc qu'ils vont multiplier les lov
et commencer à avoir des dents un petit
peu plus ipso d'autres qui commencent à
évoquer les dents de
de prob au sida moderne donc les stés
godon sont les les ancêtres les plus
directs qu'on a parmi les mastodontes
des proboscidiens moderne
donc voilà si jamais vous posiez la
question c'est quoi le mastodonte le
plus proche des proboscidiens c'est
c'était ce sont lestés go dante
évidemment le terme mastodonte je les ai
mis entre guillemets parce que vous
comprenez maintenant qu'en fait on
devrait appeler les éléphants moderne
des mastodontes mais comme je les dis le
terme mastodontes et plus choisi en
référence à une morphologie dentaire qui
est partagé par tous ces animaux que
pour désigner un groupe monofil éthiques
donc les mastodontes ce sont les
éléphants qui forment bazot mais en soi
c'est pas vraiment c'est pas c'est pas
vraiment un groupe c'est pas du tout un
groupe monofil éthique bien sûr et donc
autre chose à noter c'est que à nant cus
par exemple il a des dents qui sont ceux
qui sont rigolos faut donc c'est à dire
qu'en fait les les dans les culs speed
sont organisés presque en zigzaguant
fait et ça c'est aussi quelque chose
qu'on rencontre typiquement chez les
mastodontes
regardez cet ego dont il est cupide sont
toutes alignées d'ailleurs c'est ce qui
va faire ce que c'est ce qui fait aussi
que sté god on est plus proche des
éléphants des éléphantes idée que des
mastodontes idée que des mastodontes
c'est parce que justement il n'a pas les
danses rigolo fondre c'est à dire les
l'ofs organisant zigzag
en fait là ont ils à des lofts bien
droit donc voilà si vous aussi vous vous
retrouvez une grosse dent comme ça avec
plein qu speed organisé en zigzag
enfin des lofts organise en zigzag c'est
que vous êtes en train de regarder et
qu'elle est bracchi dont tu sais que
vous êtes en train de regarder un une
dent deux mastodontes et vous avez de
vous avez du bol de l'avoir trouvé et
puis évidemment chez les mastodontes il
va y avoir cette tendance à la
rétraction des narines qui va se
prononcer se prononcer se prononcer
jusqu'à la condition chez les éléphants
et vous allez avoir la réduction des
incisives inférieur qui vont donner les
les éléphants moderne donc celle et
encore une fois chez les ch'ti god anti
délais dans les incisives inférieurs
sont perdus ce qui les placent
directement comme groupe frère des
éléphants moderne
donc ça c'est une tendance évolutive
chez les mastodontes à la réduction d un
sixième inférieur et par exemple les
mammouths il est mammouth idées vont
aussi avoir une réduction des incisives
inférieur pas au point de les perdre
complètement mais voilà les mammouths
idée c'est ce que c'est le mastodonte
droit nord américain qui a été confondu
avec les mammouths par cuvier à la base
et donc du coup il est appelé mammites
mais voilà le c'est pas le mammouth
mamie tu n'es pas le mammouth
il n'y a pas de courants perte ça me
mute pour ceux qui connaissent le joueur
du grenier n'en perdez pas votre mute de
ce mammouth parce que le mammouth
en fait c'est pas du tout à ma mute
c'est un mastodonte c'est le mastodonte
nord-américains le mammouth le vrai
c'est mam ou tousser vous voyez qu'il ya
un monde entre les deux un mammouth est
un mastodonte mamoutou c'est un éléphant
d'idées voilà donc ne nous en qu'on ne
nous en brouillon pas n'est ce pas donc
voilà un an qu ce qu'on trouve à langast
ban verts en afrique du sud et jusqu'en
france et en asie on le retrouve partout
un tank us et c'est vraiment le
mastodonte typique à 4 défense quoi mais
évidemment quand on a quatre défense et
qu'on sait pas quoi faire des défenses
inférieur bas des fois on peut avoir de
l'imagination voici plati bello dont la
tibet l'otan qui avait donc
qui savait pas quoi [ __ ] de ces
défenses inférieur il en a fait des
pelles
voilà est alors lui par contre il est
parti donc ça c'est plat tibet le dos il
me semble que c'est ces arcs et obelo
dont si je me trompe pas mais voilà
c'est la même famille de façon c'est
plat tibet le sceller les âmes et belo
monte id donc la famille des âmes et
bello note id a évolué sept a vu
apparaître cette cette forme de pelle
sur les incisives inférieur qui est
assez cocasse parce que vraiment enfin
on a voilà ça c'est la meilleure façon
qu'on est de les reconstituer mais enfin
vous voyez déjà le grotesque de la chose
n'est ce pas voilà un truc important à
propos des mastodondes c'est que ce sont
donc les premiers et les fortifs forme a
quitté l'afrique
donc voilà le plus vieux mastodontes qui
est en fait juste un petit bout de
défense et ce petit bout de défense
il a une signature bien particulière des
vrais défenses d'éléphants qui forment
les vrais défenses d'éléphants ti forme
ont ce qu'on appelle le guillochage de
l'émail alors j'ai jamais trouvé comme
on le disait en anglais alors du coup
j'ai mis deux mots en français
il ya un guillochage de l'émail ce qui
fait qu'en fait les les fibres de
dentine pas de l'émail pardon de la
dentine guillochage de la dentine ou de
l'ivoire donc les fibres d'ivoire soit
orgas on se croise dans les trois
dimensions en fait donc vous ça vous
donne cette espèce dirige dirigé sens
assez bizarre qui est complètement
unique aux éléphants ti forn on a trouvé
nulle part ailleurs et donc ce petit
bout de défense il a été retrouvé au
pakistan et du cou et du coup ça indique
ça indique que les éléphants étaient
auteurs ont un talent au pakistan et ils
datent de l'oligocène donc on est un
petit peu avant que la connexion soit
complètement établie entre l'afrique est
le continent asiatique
la vraie connexion va vraiment se former
la grosse connexion va vraiment se
former que healy à 21 millions d'années
mais déjà la fan de ligue 1 c'est non on
commence à avoir des échanges parce que
les deux continents commence vraiment
être rapprochés et qui à la glaciation
qui en route
rappelez-vous le courant circumpolaire
la glaciation et en route les eaux sont
en train de régresser donc les ponts
continentaux sont en train de se former
donc déjà l'oligocène supérieur on a des
éléphants des mastodontes qui commencent
à quitter l'afrique et on a les entraco
terre donc les ancêtres des hippopotames
idée qui rentre déjà dès la fin de
l'oligocène mais c'est vraiment qu'à
partir de 21 millions d'années donc au
tout début du miocène que les choses
vont se gâter et que les connexions vont
vraiment s'établir entre que la
connexion entre le l'asie et l'afrique
va vraiment se former et c'est là qu'on
va avoir justement la déferlante de tous
ces animaux qu'on considère comme
africains et qui ne sont pas du tout en
réalité les rhino les antilopes
les zèbres eux
et puis les lions enfin les ancêtres des
lions n'y a pas encore de lyon à
l'époque mais les big 4 les félins les
félidés vont arriver en afrique
seulement à ce moment là avant l'arrivée
des félins en afrique les les carnivores
dominance sont pas des se sont pas des
afro terre les carnivores dominants sont
des yellow dotted et donc on en
reparlera on en parlera sur le court sur
l'évolution des carnivores deadeye
notons idée mais voilà les carnivores
dominant en afrique n'était pas les
grands félins avant le minot scène donc
voilà c'est là qu'ils sont arrivés les
ancêtres de toutes ces bestioles hélas
pas vous imaginer des [ __ ] même pas
de lapin quoi donc parce que le rôle
était pris par les irak seul et le rôle
des ars sud at il été pris par les irak
le rôle des rhinocéros était pris par
les irak ce le rôle des tapirs et des
hippopotames été pris par les éléphants
bon ben on avait il y avait d'autres
afro terre et là en fait ceux qui vous
sont représentés ici c'est ce qu'ils ont
réussi quand même mine de rien à avoir
un petit succès évolutif en dehors
d'afrique malgré le fait qu'ils sont
faits poutre et sur leur propre terrain
donc les irak ce que je vous ai montré
au milieu scène ils vont se répandre un
petit peu en eurasie
il y aura les oryctérope qui vont se
répandre un petit peu on a même un
oryctérope qui a été trouvée dans les
sables pliocène de perpignan donc on a
deux l'oryctérope en france
évidemment les mastodontes et est même
après eux les éléphantes idées vont se
répandre à travers le monde et vont
avoir un succès évolutif incroyable à
travers le monde
donc c'est un échange alors qui a
globalement joué en la défaveur des
paiements gueulé parce qu'il ya quand
même beaucoup plus d'espèces de paix
n'ont vu les cons morfler en afrique que
d'espèces darciaux dactylo de perry sow
qui ont qui ont morflé en asie mais mais
mais mais voilà les les éléphants vont
quand même trouvé les pennons bull et
vont quand même trouvé un certain succès
aussi sur le continent eurasiatique et
un succès qui est relatif pour les irak
aux ide mais qui est absolu pour les
pour les éléphants ti forme il faut
savoir alors c'est pas c'est pas
exactement à l'eau ligue 1 c'est pas
exactement à la fin de l'oligocène au
début du miocène que ça se produit mais
en europe il s'est passé quelque chose
de similaire
l'europe était un archipel d'îles avant
la fin de l'éocène et et il s'est passé
plus ou moins la même histoire le fan de
l'éocène la glaciation commence etc
sauf que là les là il n'y avait pas
besoin d'une grosse baisse du niveau
marin pour que ces ils se retrouvent
connecter à l'asie en fait les archipels
européens se sont retrouvés connecter à
l'asie et l'appareil vous avez eu la
déferlante l'énorme déferlante qui a
provoqué l'extinction de toute les faune
endémique qui avait en europe à l'époque
donc et ça on l'a appelée la grande
coupure et même les américains pour le
coup l'appel la grande coupure parce que
c'est le vrai nom de 7 et donc cette
grande coupure finalement c'est
l'équivalent européen de ce qui s'est
passé en afrique il ya 21 millions
d'années c'est juste que ça s'est passé
un peu avant et en parallèle des
mastodontes en fait il y a eu une autre
histoire des proboscidiens il ya une
double histoire qui ce qui se déroule en
parallèle celle de l'évolution des
mastodontes qui conduit aux éléphants
moderne mais il ya aussi l'évolution des
notaires idée donc à partir des
éléphants bazzo dont on parlait tout à
l'heure les des notaires idée en fait
vont
vont tirer les prolongations les des
notaires idée vous voyez il conserve la
morphologie lofo d'hondt très typique
c'est juste que bon bah ils ont ils ont
une prémolaires pardon une première
molaire qui a 3 nov
mais les dents sont fortement l'eau
faisons que vous voyez il n'y a pas les
culs speed mastodontes comme on peut les
voir chez les vaches et les mastodontes
justement chez les éléphants tifour mme
bazzo les des notaires idées ont aussi
cette particularité quand gros leurs
ancêtres avaient d une paire de défense
au dessus une paire de défense en
dessous les des notaires idées ont perdu
la paire de défense supérieure dont les
incisives la perdre à sisyphe supérieur
est complètement disparu chez les des
notaires et la paire d'as hiziv
inférieure est devenue une paire de
défense tourner vers le bas et ça c'est
très très très particulier aux des
notaires idée donc hélas la deuxième
prémolaires est absente donc mais comme
de toute façon les des notaires idées
non pas un renouvellement dentaire en
tapis roulant c'est pas du tout un
problème pour eux de perdre une autre
prémolaires s'est tant que cette
prémolaires est très fortement mollahs
reform évidemment d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs je ne les ai pas dit mais
c'est vrai que les mastodontes c'est
aussi chez eux que les voeux que la le
renouvellement dentaire en tapis roulant
va apparaître donc ça paraît chez
erythrée sommes donc erythrée homme qui
est très très proche de palais au
mastodonte dans bien des aspects je veux
dire c'est il devait ressembler à ça
erythrée sommes donc erythrée homme est
aussi le premier a évolué le
renouvellement dentaire d'arrière vers
l'avant si typique des proboscidiens
moderne
donc voilà erythrée sommes là vous avez
fio miala vous avez palais au mastodonte
il serait un petit peu plus banal en
fait que les mammouths idée donc il se
brancherait l'a finalement à la base
donc erythrée homme qui vient de
l'erythrée en fait du pays qui s'appelle
l'erythrée mais les délits notaire eux
ils n'ont pas ce renouvellement dentaire
en tapis roulant ils ont le
renouvellement dentaire malien classique
et donc les des notaires ils sont connus
pour avoir donné parmi les proboscidiens
les plus grands donc notamment d
terium giganteum que vous voyez derrière
moi sur cette photo alors cette photo
fait pas vraiment justice à la taille
des notaires y sommes gigantesques bon
déjà parce qu'elle est pris de travers
mais surtout parce que le squelette est
monté dans un trou et je suis très en
avant du squelette donc sa fausse
énormément les perspectives
mais là la mâchoire que vous voyez ici à
peu près la même hauteur que moi et vous
pouvez voir quels m'arrive gentiment à
l'épaule donc là là il ya une hauteur de
moi même rien que sur le crâne donc vous
pouvez imaginer la longueur des jambes
de cet animal c'est absolument
incroyable
et donc grâce à ses dames notaire on
peut on peut visualiser assez facilement
en fait ce que la diversification des
proboscidiens au cours de l'oligocène et
du miocène de partants débat des
proboscidiens bazzo avec des défenses au
dessus sur la mâchoire du dessus et la
mâchoire du dessous vous avez ces deux
branches qui vont se diviser
celle d'aider notre idée qui pendant le
l'oligocène et demi aux scènes et un
petit peu du pliocène vont donner des
proboscidiens
des deux grands proboscidiens avec des
défenses uniquement vers le bas et avec
d une morphologie below fo dont tu es tu
sens
cent deux cents renouvellement dentaire
à tapis et l'autre branche au miocène va
acquérir une morphologie mastodonte va
acquérir le renouvellement dentaire en
tapis roulant et va conserver les deux
paires de défense jusqu'à ce qu'on
atteigne lester godon idées les
éléphants moderne
voilà voilà l'histoire la belle histoire
et la quasi totalité des 250 espèces
dont je vous parlais se trouve ici
pendant le mieux ce n est le pliocène
c'est principalement là que ça se passe
donc voici où se branchent les des
notaires idées dont vous voyez vraiment
deux histoires en parallèle évidemment
ici la justice n'est pas rendue à la
diversité des notaires idées qui sont
juste représentée comme une seule
branche
mais voilà il faut il vraiment
s'imaginer deux branches en parallèle
qui jusqu au pliocène vont se côtoyer en
fête et se partager le monde mais vous
pouvez vous imaginer assez facilement
que vu qu'ils ont des dentitions très
différente n'y a pas eu vraiment de
soucis pour pour le partage des
ressources entre des notaires et des
mastodontes et on termine donc avec les
éléphantes idée c'est à dire le groupe
des éléphants moderne donc qui inclut
l'éléphant d'asie d'asie pardon et les
faces maximus l'éléphant d'afrique
loxodonta africana et les mammouths les
mammouths font partie des des éléphantes
idée donc les éléphantes idées sont
issus des cités god anti déchets qu'il
est chez qui alors on va passer
directement la diapo suivante donc les
ils sont issus des stés godon ti des
voiliers qui était donc des mastodontes
à dentition bracchi d'hondt qui ont
multiplié le nombre de lov et chez qui
les lofts donc se sont alignés donc ils
ne sont pas igolo fondante
donc les love se sont alignés et à
partir de cette morphologie en fait ce
tte golo folle honte
c'est ainsi qu'on les appelle vous allez
avoir augmentation de la couronne de la
taille de la couronne au pléistocène qui
va donner les morphologies dentaire des
éléphants tels qu'on les connaît
aujourd'hui
donc finalement les dent d'éléphant
moderne sait jamais que des dans dust et
godon de stégosaure idée mais à couronne
très très hot
ipso dont tu es ça et ça c'est ça c'est
à corréler évidemment avec une
adaptation à un mode de vie grammy
nivore donc les éléphants sont un peu
les retardataires dans l'histoire
rappelez-vous la plupart des groupes
commencent à s'adapter à la grameen
ivory aux dés le début du miocène les
éléphants vont commencer ça uniquement
au pliocène et vont vraiment y aller
franco qu au pléistocène
voilà donc s'il ya vraiment qu au
pléistocène qu'on commence à avoir des
espèces d' elephant idées à dentition
fortement ips dont tu et ça ne veut pas
dire qu au pléistocène y avait pas
encore des espèces avec des dents bras
qui dompte les les mammouths idées dont
l'origine évolutive se branchent par là
au milieu scène les mammouths idées vont
survivre jusqu'à il y a dix mille ans
donc très loin dans le pléistocène donc
les les ancêtres les ancêtres des
éléphants moderne était plus tôt
follivores et frugivores eux
et les éléphants modernes se sont
adaptés finalement à la grameen ivory
donc au mode de hausse à vannes et au
step les mammouths vont avoir grand
succès dans les steppes évidemment mais
il faut pas perdre de vue que le c'est
pas pour autant que les frugivores ont
disparu donc même les mammouths idées
vont persister jusqu'à très tard jusqu'à
la fin de la dernière glaciation dix
mille ans et c'est très récent et
peut-être sicile les êtres humains
n'étaient pas arrivés à ce moment là en
amérique du nord peut-être qu'ils y
aurait survécu à la dernière glaciation
on a on a un peu de mal à le déterminer
parce que la vérité c'est que c'est que
comme il ya un changement climatique et
l'arrivée de l'homme au même moment
c'est un peu dur de déterminer à qui la
faute
mais c'est probablement une combinaison
des deux et peut-être que s'il n'y avait
pas eu combinaison des deux on aurait
encore
une diversité de propos cydia qui serait
équivalente à ce qu'elles étaient encore
au pléistocène
donc quand on regarde un éléphant
d'afrique d'afrique ou un éléphant
d'asie
voilà les vous avez le même type de
danse ipso dont tu avec juste le nombre
de l'offre qui change
et là où c'est intéressant et bien c'est
que les mammouths ce que vous voyez ici
et là les mammouths
ils ont plein de petits l'ofs resserré
comme les éléphants d'asie et donc
depuis très longtemps on pense que les
mammouths sont reliés aux éléphants
d'asie plus que les éléphants d'asie
n'sont relief éléphants d'afrique et la
vérité c'est que les analyses génétiques
ont confirmé ça avec vous voyez la
branche des loxodonta africana qui
diverge en premier et ensuite le groupe
frère formé par les éléphants d'afrique
d'asie
je vais y arriver les éléphants d'asie
et les mammouths donc les éléphants
d'asie et les mammouths sont plus
proches l'un de l'autre qu'ils ne que
l'éléphant d'asie moderne ne l'aident
l'éléphant d'afrique moderne et ça quand
même je trouve que ça troue le cul de se
dire que finalement les mammouths sait
jamais que des éléphants d'asie poilus
au final alors c'est des éléphants
d'asie poilus oui mais pas tous pas tous
alors ce qui caractérise réellement les
mammouths ce sont leur défense les
éléphants d'asie comme d'afrique ont des
ondées défense relativement droite
les éléphants les mammouths eux ils ont
des défenses qui ont cette courbure très
caractéristique que vous voyez ici aussi
et cette courbure caractéristique c'est
sa forme presque d'aider des bras qui
embrasse comme ça qu'ils essaient
d'attraper devant donc c'est vraiment ça
qui caractérise les mammouths et le fait
est que cette morphologie on peut la
trace est très très loin dans le temps
et là vous voyez donc a résumé du
registre fossile des mammouths vous avez
le temps millions d'années vous avez la
hauteur de la couronne dentaire est en
fait si vous retracer en arrière l'adq
ou la hauteur de la couronne dentaire et
bien vous trouvez des espèces de plus en
plus primitive est de plus en plus
anciennes jusqu'à mamou tous su
planifieront ce même mot tous su
planifieront sous
voirie là il est très faiblement ipso
dante à comparer aux mammouths
méridionale où au mammouth alors tron go
terry ils vivent est allé à la même
époque le
non même pas il vivait un peu avant le
mammouth laineux mammouth laineux ses
prix me genius mais vous pouvez imprimer
genius avait à peu près la même hauteur
de dents voire même un peu plus haute
donc non bref vous avez une ipso dont
six qui est plutôt réduite chez mamoutou
dessus planifie mais surtout mamoutou su
planifieront ça a été découvert à
langast bande verte en afrique du sud
donc les mammouths ont une origine
africaine
et pas n'importe quel africaine le sud
de l'afrique dont vraiment loi loi en
bas à quoi loin loin loin dans le sud de
l'afrique profondément africaine donc ça
c est ce qui veut dire que mammouth ou
sup l'animent france j'y vivais dans un
climat tout à fait tropicale l'afrique
du sud à l'époque était tout à fait
tropicale il ya 5 millions d'années donc
on avait un mammouth qui n'avaient pas
de poils mais par contre il a le dos qui
est voiliers qui penche vers l'arrière
comme ça comme le mammouth laineux et il
a de ses défenses très courbé qui
embrasse la trompe finalement comme le
mammouth laineux mais il ya que le
mammouth laineux qui était l'aîné en
réalité c'est pas tout les mammouths qui
étaient les noeuds voilà donc vous aurez
appris que les mammouths ont une origine
africaine
1 elle est pas belle la vie évidemment
dans vous avez quand vous avez une
diversité telles que celles des
mammouths et des éléphantes idées en
général bas vous avez une divergence
vous avez une diversification qui se
fait non seulement
vers des tailles gigantesques donc là
vous avez par exemple paléologue ce don
qui était un des plus grands et les non
pardon paléologue ce don est ici qui
étaient là des plus grands éléphantidé
vous avez le mammouth méridionale qui
était aussi appelé le mammouth imperator
ils étaient gigantesques aussi vous avez
certains mastodontes qui ont atteint des
détails gigantesque aussi là on parle
d'animaux les plus grands mammouth les
plus grands éléphants moderne qui ont
été abattus
c'était au début du siècle dernier et il
faisait 11 tonnes et déjà 11 tonnes
c'est un mal c'est un mal qui fait déjà
deux fois la taille qu'il devrait faire
pour un éléphant d'afrique un éléphant
d'afrique de 11 tonnes c'est déjà deux
fois plus gros que la taille kamal
moyens fait mais là faut vous imaginer
qu'à l'époque il y avait des palais au
look so dont et tout ça on flirte on
flirte en taille moyenne justement avec
les 9 à 12 tonnes en taille moyenne et
il ya possiblement des individus
2 qui ont pu atteindre les 20 tonnes si
ça se trouve enfin bon après les
estimations de taille corporelle chez
les espèces éteintes voilà allez voir
notre notre vidéo sur le brachiosaure
évidemment que c'est pas une science
exacte
voilà mais c'est tout résumé mais voilà
on est on est quand même sur des animaux
qui de toute façon on a les squelettes
complets les squelettes complets sont
gigantesques donc une diversification de
taille non seulement vers le haut ce
qu'on considérait comme normal pour les
éléphants mais aussi vers le bas vers
des éléphants de toute petite petite
taille comme ce petit éléphant d'un de
sicile paléo loxodonta falco neri donc
paléo l'occident falco neri donc vous
voyez c'est le même genre que celui là
un palais au look so do antique us pas
les hawks au don l'antique us c'est
l'ancêtre direct ii paléologue solo
falco neri et la transition entre les
deux est assez bien documenté et et le
fait est que là vous ce que vous
regardez c'est pas un juvénile regardez
la taille des défenses les défenses sont
bien développés c'est pas un juvénile
c'est un adulte et c'est un mâle chez
paléologue son dauphin de conneries on a
des mâles des femelles on sait que les
femelles avait pas de défense donc là on
regarde un adulte mâle et vous voyez
qu'il est minuscule
les dernières estimations de masse qui
ont été réalisés par une équipe
italienne le place à peu près à 180
kilos donc 180 kilos c'est le poids d'un
bébé éléphant moderne voilà voire même
voici c'est un peu ça c'est le point
c'est à peu près ça le boisne le poids
d'un bébé éléphant me regarde et vous
n'aviez pas qu'il n'y avait pas que lui
il y avait aussi des mammouths acquis et
ena il y avait des stés godon qui est n
a donc aidé ça s'est répété plusieurs
fois c'est à dire qu'il ya pas qu une
espèce il ya au moins trois espèces de
paléo l'occident qui sont devenus une
haine il ya aussi une adresse ici par
exemple
les mammouths n'a y en a plein aussi des
il ya eu les mammouths laineux qui sont
devenus n'at il ya eu les mains mouthe
américains qui sont devenus n'at il ya
eu plein d'exemples et notamment
méditerranée d'ailleurs les éléphants
nains c'est surtout en méditerranée
qu'on les trouve et lester god anti
d'hénin on en a eu en asie en indonésie
on en a eu en au japon donc voila et
encore une fois c'est très bien
documenté parce qu'on retrouve les dents
et on voit les dents rétrécir au fur et
à mesure du temps donc voilà tout ça
c'est très très bien documenté et du
coup c'est possiblement la découverte de
bain d'un crâne d'éléphants d'un de
sicile ou de n'importe quel autre
éléphants nains en méditerranée
justement qui a conduit au mythe du
cyclope par la faim par l'avs à
l'invention du mythe du cyclope parle
justement les populations
méditerranéennes les grecs notamment
donc voilà petit diapos finale pour
résumer la simplicité la simplicité
rustique de l'histoire des éléphants
alors je vais vous déchiffrer tous à
vous en faites pas mais en gros en bleu
l'histoire commence en bleu au paléo
scène à l'eocène à le ligoter n vous
avez le développement des proboscidiens
bazzo qui ressemble globalement à des
tapirs un groupe plutôt discret niveau
diversité comparé aux irak aux ide et
puis arrive le mieux scène donc entre 21
et 18 millions d'années et là c'est
l'explosion de diversité donc les
mastodontes apparaissent à la fin de
l'oligocène et se dispersent dans le
monde
et quand je dis dans le monde va vous
suivez les rouges là donc à partir des
rouges vous voyez les mastodontes
apparaître et les dinos terre idée aussi
qui apparaissent et ses deux lignes et
vont conquérir le monde
littéralement donc les dinos terium va
atteindre l'asie
il va atteindre l'europe on a trouvé
plein plein plein de dino terium en
europe ça a même donné lieu à des mythes
de géants comme celui de tutos baucus
par exemple ce qui a été découvert qui a
été découvert dans le sud de la france
mais il ya plein de dino terry dès
qu'ils ont été découverts il ya
énormément de mastodontes ya notamment
gonfo terium donc je sais pas si vous
vous rappelez mail
si vous avez lu la diapo mais
l'événement qui a lieu il ya 21 millions
d'années donc cette ouverture se
de l'afrique au reste du monde ça
s'appelle le gong sonne le gong fu
terium datum event donc c'est
l'événement à gontaud terium parce que à
cette époque-là goffaux terium le
mastodonte de gauche faute à riols se
retrouve absolument partout et très
soudainement donc on le retrouve en
europe par exemple du côté de toulouse
en france à 100 cents on le retrouve en
asie est on est on retrouve même des
mastodontes jusqu'en amérique du nord
qui vont donner justement la lignée qui
va devenir le mammouth le mastodonte
américain et qui va perdurer jusque
jusqu'à il ya dix mille ans donc et vous
avez les des notaires idées qu'ils
n'atteindront pas l'amérique mais qui
vont aussi conquérir l'asie et l'europe
est lady notaire idées qui vont pareil
survivre jusqu'à il y a cinq millions
d'années ou voir même plus récemment que
ça et puis la troisième vague de
migration ça va être les éléphantes idée
donc avec
avec les ancêtres des éléphants moderne
donc vous avez l'éléphant d'afrique qui
va pas quitter l'afrique évidemment mais
la vague de migration qui va aller en
asie et qui va donner ultime mans
l'éléphant d'asie et c'est pour ça que
maintenant on allait enfin en asie en
afrique c'est suite à cette troisième
vague de migration il entre 5 et 2
millions d'années donc qui correspond au
pliocène et vous avez de nouveau une
vague de migrants qui va atteindre
l'amérique du nord au plié au
pléistocène
et cette vague de migrants s'est
notamment les mammouths voilà et en
parallèle il ya des représentants de
l'ancien vague de migration donc des
mammouths pas des mammouths des
mammouths des mastodontes qui vont
quitter l'amérique du nord et même
réussir à atteindre l'amérique du sud il
ya deux millions d'années
donc il ya deux millions d'années se
forment l'isthme de panama qui
n'existait pas jusque là l'amérique du
sud était complètement isolé et on va en
parler dans le très bientôt dans on aura
une classe
une leçon qui sera complètement dédiée à
l'amérique du sud
mais voilà spoiler alert l'amérique du
sud était complètement isolé est resté
complètement isolée par le sénat zurich
mais il ya un pont de terre qui se forme
il ya deux millions d'années qui est
l'isthme de panama
et là paf les mastodontes is arif et
s'adonne cuvier rogneuse donc mastodonte
nommé en l'honneur de cuvier
voilà donc célèbre paléontologue
français et puis évidemment vous avez
dans cette vague de migration ceux qui
ont atteint a donné 10 donc imaginé il
ya deux millions d'années
il ya des éléphants partout absolument
partout il ya qu en australie qui a pas
d'éléphant regardez il y en a au japon
il y en a un en indonésie il y en a en
europe et en asie en am en amérique du
nord en amérique du sud il ya que au
japon qui a pas d'éléphants vielles
enfin c1
c'est vraiment un truc de fou quand même
et donc est ce qu'il ya de formidable
avec les éléphants c'est que malgré leur
grande taille il évolue très vite ils se
dispersent très loin donc cédé
formidable fossiles stratigraphique ça
permet de dater les roches avec une
précision incroyable parce que les dents
se conserve très bien ils sont très
facilement reconnaissable et morphologie
dentaires sont différentes d'une espèce
à une autre et se distingue très
nettement et on la trouve partout
donc donc c'est vraiment les fossiles
qu'on us pour la biostratigraphie de
façon assez récurrente
parce que c'est tellement c'est
tellement pratique en fait sont
tellement diverse
donc voilà les l'histoire des éléphants
c'est une histoire grandiose c'est une
histoire de migration c'est une histoire
c'est une c'est une histoire c'est une
success story voilà j'essaie de traduire
le mot success story je n'y arrive pas
voilà c'est un succès évolutif
gigantesque succès qui n'a d'égal que le
que que la culotte je veux pas dire la
catastrophe mais voilà c'est dit il
reste plus rien aujourd'hui reste plus
rien de cette diversité et c'est d'une
tristesse assez affligeante
c'est pas dû qu'à l'être humain je veux
dire les éléphants sont toujours
présents en afrique alors que l'homme a
évolué en afrique donc c'est pas du que
à l'être humain et la disparition des
proboscidiens en amérique du nord il ya
une bonne corrélation entre l'arrivée de
l'être humain et des éléphants comme je
les dis mais en europe et tout ça le
principal coupable il faut qu'on va pas
se cacher c'est essentiellement les la
glaciation
la dernière grande glaciation et la fin
de la dernière grande glaciation plus
précisément qui pour une raison
blizzard a eu plus d'effet que la fin
des autres glaciation parce que je
rappelle que les glaciations enfin le ce
qu'on appelle l'âge de glace en fait
c'est plein de petit âge de glace
entrecoupées d'interviews la siere donc
interglaciaire pendant lesquelles il
faisait chaud pendant les interclasses
hier on pouvait retrouver des
hippopotames jusqu en angleterre
donc c'est bizarre c'est bizarre comment
on en est arrivé à un monde avec
seulement trois espèces de proboscidiens
alors qu'il avait conquis le monde
mystère et boule de gomme donc voilà
petit diapos résumé vous pouvez la lire
si ça vous intéresse c'est pas tellement
c'est ça résume exactement ce que je
vais vous dire
donc je vous dis à très bientôt pour une
prochaine leçon donc la prochaine ce
sera sur les carnivores donc de ne la
manquez pas on va parler enfin des
bestioles qui bouffe de la viande
je sais bien que les carnivores ça
intéresse toujours plus que de parler
des herbivores mais les herbivores sont
tellement tellement une histoire qui est
tellement intéressante que ça aurait été
dommage de ne pas commencer par ça mais
voilà ça y est on va enfin parler de il
va enfin y avoir un peu d'action
voilà donc je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine ciao